Buenos Dias, Linus.
Buenos Dias, Tim.
Heute haben wir historien divertidas und educativer über die Artificial Intelligence,
ohne den raten und ohne den Elefanten.
Das war Spanisch.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 527 vom 24.
Juni 2025.
Und keiner von uns ist jetzt der Elefant und keiner ist die Maus.
Keiner ist die Maus.
Das hätten wir schon mal unter uns ein bisschen auslosen können, oder?
Du hattest ja den Ralf Kaspers schon mal in Forschergeist und den Armin Maywald in CRE.
Das ist ja quasi dann die Mausrede fanden.
Genau, die beiden. Die Mausrede fanden, genau. Da ist auch klar, wer wer ist.
Ja.
Ein interessantes Universum, muss man sagen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall,
wahrhaft ein wahrhaftes deutsches Kulturgut, das kann man echt nicht anders darstellen und das,
kann man auch mit den Lobpreisungen und Kulturreferenzen nicht gar nicht zu
wenig irgendwie leisten.
Ja, sollen wir jetzt schon verraten, warum wir ein Maus-Intro haben?
Ja, weil du rumgeprollt hast auf den Kanälen.
Ich habe die höchste Auszeichnung, die für einen Erklärer, die einen Erklärer
bekommen kann, habe ich erlangt.
Ich habe da durchgescrollt, ich habe keinen Dinos gesehen.
Also das gibt es ja wohl nicht. Also in der aktuellen Maus vom 22.
Du hast wahrscheinlich unten geguckt. Ich stehe aber unter Ralf Kaspers.
Ralf Kaspers, Linus Neumann, Jannis Quer. Im Abspann der aktuellen Maul.
Ja, da steht dein Name. Ich dachte ja, du tauchst ja jetzt auch auf und sagst
ein Sprüchlein auf oder erklärst irgendwas.
Ich war die Maus!
Im Mauskostüm.
Hast du mich nicht erkannt? Es war außerdem...
Ich hatte kurz bei Sean das Schaf, hatte ich so ein bisschen meine Frage.
Es war außerdem die,
Sendung mit einem coolsten Mauselefanten,
Zwischenspieler, das war nach dem Beitrag, an dem Jannis und ich mitgewirkt
hatten, wo die Zahlen durchlaufen, diese Cybermaus und Cyberelefanten,
die flippen immer so Bits und dann verändern sie sich. Also herausragend.
Jannis und ich haben an dem Skript ein bisschen mitgewirkt, was in der Sendung
Künstliche Intelligenz vermittelt.
Janis ist ein Arbeitskollege von mir und Freund von mir, der dieses mit dem
Machine Learning studiert hat.
Und wir haben beide ein bisschen an dem sehr wenig zu dem Skript beigetragen.
Ich hatte auch eigentlich nicht gedacht, dass wir am Ende dafür einen Credit
bekommen würden, aber der Ralf hat ja extra geschrieben, hier,
jetzt kommt die Sendung und guck die.
Und dann haben wir natürlich geguckt und erst später wurde ich darauf aufmerksam
gemacht, dass wir in den Credits sind.
Das ist irre. Also es ist wirklich, da kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen,
wie wir uns ein Loch im Bauch gefreut haben.
Das ist echt lustig. Den ganzen Tag quillst du aus allen Tagesschau-Sendungen
raus, aber wenn du mal bei meiner Maus im Abspann stehst, das ist dann sozusagen der Peak.
Okay, ich kann das auch nachvollziehen.
Also das ist einfach, das ist dann doch, ja, Ja, das ist schon,
das ist schon, ja, muss ich echt sagen, freue mich.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall große, große Freude für uns alle.
Jannis hat Familie, was meinst du, wie der jetzt dasteht? Also der ist ja jetzt einfach der King.
Schon ganz gut. Und übrigens auch so Freunde, von denen du lange nichts gehört
hast. Ich hab dich im Mausabspann gesehen.
Du lest im Mausabspann.
Das ist bemerkenswert. Es ist doch schön, dass da überhaupt noch Fernsehen geguckt
wird, dass das Programm sozusagen noch verfolgt wird.
Ich weiß nicht, so richtig sicher kann man sich da ja nicht unbedingt immer sein.
Bei der Maus schon. Das ist ein angestammtes Ding.
Ja, da habe ich sehr gefreut.
Und mit wem hast du dann zusammengearbeitet? Hast du direkt mit dem Ralf Kaspers zusammengearbeitet?
Genau, ja, also der Ralf macht ja auch andere Szenen, Quarks und Kaspers zum Beispiel, wo THS und ich,
schon vor war es auch bald das ist auch schon wieder 16 ne, 6,
7 Jahre her ne, 9 Jahre her und er war ja auch zum Beispiel auf dem CCC Camp und dadurch haben wir,
einen losen Austausch immer mal wieder zu Themenunternehmen auch mal irgendwie,
dass er sagte, wir wollen KI erklären und gib doch mal Feedback und dann haben
wir da ein bisschen was zu gesagt und,
das ist auch schon länger her und wie gesagt, der Beitrag war jetzt auch nicht,
fundamental, aber offenbar,
ausreichend groß, dass wir da gewürdigt wurden und das hat Janis und ich sehr mit Stolz gefüllt.
Ja, er hat auch einen Vortrag gehalten, auf dem Camp damals und das kann er
auch gerne mal auf dem Kongress machen.
Ja, ich glaube Kongress, das ist das übliche Problem.
Das klassische Problem, ungünstiger Zeitpunkt zwischen den Jahren und Camp habe
ich natürlich auch die letzten beiden Male angeklopft, da hat er dann auch wieder
irgendeine fadenscheinige Ausrede präsentiert.
Fadenscheinig.
Na gut. Gut. Aber weil wir so jetzt, oder weil du jetzt vor allem so im Schwung
bist, werden wir dann auch nochmal ein bisschen erklären, wie das ist eigentlich so.
Mit dem KI, weil das bewegt ja die Leute, das bewegt auch unsere Kommentare
und das bewegt die Öffentlichkeit und das aus gutem Grund.
Genau. Aber wir machen trotzdem unser Housekeeping, wenn wir jetzt eh schon
die Maus vorgenommen haben.
Ich war außerdem letzte Woche in der Sendung Apokalypse und Filterkaffee,
obwohl ich ja wirklich keinen Filterkaffee trinke,
habe ich auch in der Sendung Eisenhardt Espresso getrunken mit Jagoda Marinitsch,
die ja auch den Podcast Freiheit Deluxe macht, in dem ich vor einiger Zeit auch
mal zu Gast war und wir haben da auch eine schöne Unterhaltung gehabt.
Mich ebenfalls gefreut.
Warst du auch mal gespannt sozusagen.
Also ich muss sagen, die Maus scheint dann doch nochmal mehr Reichweite zu haben
von dem Feedback, was bei mir ankam.
Und vor allem, also ein Maus-Abspannserwähnung kriegt mehr Feedback,
das bei mir ankommt, als eine Apokalypse und Filterkaffee, wo auch schon Feedback kommt, aber ja.
Warten wir mal ab, was passiert, wenn die Maus erst bei Logbuch-Netzpolitik
ist. dann ist richtig Alarm.
Wenn wir uns ja hier auf das Board legen. Ach ne, du hast mir da andere Sachen drauf gemacht. Okay.
Wir sollten aber auch noch kurz das Feedback der letzten Sendung huldigen.
Es gab ein paar interessante Informationen, zum Beispiel von Kipfal,
der unsere Postleitzahl Konfusion mit österreichischen Postleitzahlen,
korrigiert und schreibt, man kann schon anhand der Postleitzahlen die Wiener
Gemeindebezirke identifizieren. Sie sind durchnummeriert vom 1.
Bezirk Innere Stadt bis zum 23.
Bezirk Leasing. Und in den entsprechenden Postleitzahlen findet sich das in
der 2. und 3. Ziffer wieder.
1 0 1 0 entspricht also dem 1. Bezirk und 1 2 3 0 dem 23. Bezirk.
In Wien beginnen die Postleitzahlen immer mit 1 als 1. Ziffer.
Die vierte Ziffer stünde für das Bestimmungspostamt innerhalb des jeweiligen Bezirks.
Im Alltag lautet die letzte Ziffer innerhalb Wiens aber fast immer 0.
Warum das so ist, hinterfrage ich gerade zum ersten Mal.
Vermutlich ist das der Einfachheit beim Adressieren geschuldet.
Ja, liebe Grüße aus 1170. Das ist welcher Bezirk?
17. Ach, Messerschaft.
Du bist einfach klar und in der Birne und einfach dabei. Linus,
das muss ich jetzt mal anerkennend feststellen.
Ja, also beknackte Zähler, also ich meine 1170 ist das in meiner Wahrnehmung,
aber offenbar ist es 1170 gesprochen.
Ja, 1170 und wenn man richtig was ist im 17.
Bezirk und eine richtig große Nummer ist, dann kann man vielleicht auch nochmal
eine eigene Postleitzahl beantragen.
Das ist sozusagen nochmal ein neues Live-Go, jetzt wo das mit der Sendung mit der Maus durch ist.
Ach so.
Eine eigene Postleitzahl in Wien.
1, 3, 3, 7 wäre meine Postleitzahl.
Also ich hätte, ja, ich weiß nicht, 23. Bezirk finde ich ja ganz geil.
Also für 1, 2, 3, 5 würde ich mich durchaus bewerben.
Keine Ahnung, wie das in Leasing so ist.
Aber Leasing machen ja heutzutage viele Leute, habe ich gehört.
Das ist durchaus populär.
Ja, verstehe.
Stefan hat noch einen Kommentar zu unseren Ausführungen zur National Guard.
Mir war schon in der Sendung so ein bisschen alles durcheinander.
Du hast mich ja auch da die ganze Zeit korrigiert, weil ich hatte immer so das
Gefühl, so National Guard, das ist doch eher so eine lokale Geschichte in den USA.
Ja, ist auch so. Stefan sagt, die National Guards sind die Milizen der Bundesstaaten.
Die haben in der Tat auch Luftwaffen und so weiter, aber sie sind separat von
der United States Army, also dem Heer und United States Air Force des Bundes.
Sie unterstehen den jeweiligen Gouverneuren, die sind auch im Irak und so weiter dabei.
Der Präsident kann beim jeweiligen Gouverneurtruppen anfragen.
Donald Trump hat aber wieder ein Notfallgesetz ausgenutzt, um sie gegen den
Willen des Gouverneurs loszuschicken. Das ist sozusagen hier die eigentliche Information.
Die ich auch nicht so richtig mitbekommen habe. Aber dann klärt sich zumindest
mein komisches Gefühl, was ich in dem Moment hatte.
Okay, also kommandiert von der staatlichen Exekutive, nicht von der Bundesexekutive.
Genau, die werden halt gerufen, wenn große Katastrophen sind.
Gewaltbrand und so weiter oder Unruhen gerne, aber das ist halt eigentlich der
Call vom jeweiligen Gouverneur,
was in dem Fall halt ein demokratischer Gouverneur gewesen wäre,
in dem Fall Kalifornien, aber Trump hat wieder irgendein Notfallgesetz aktiviert
und gesagt, ja hier Notfall,
und selber das Kommando übernommen,
wie es ja jetzt schon mehrfach passiert ist, auch mit den Zöllen und jetzt eben auch mit dem,
mit dem Einsatz im Iran.
Ja, doppelt geschmacklos.
Ja, aber ist auch schon wieder vorbei, gab ja dann direkt das nächste Thema.
Aber wir sollen nicht so viel über Iran, Israel und Trump sprechen.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt nicht.
Genau. So, historias divertidas y educativas haben wir jetzt noch.
Ja. Über,
Intelligencia artificial. Wir wollten ein bisschen die Gelegenheit nutzen,
der Themenarmut, es ist ja nichts los in der Welt, über das wir reden dürfen in dieser Sendung.
Das ist richtig. Wir müssen echt schlau sein.
Deswegen nutzen wir die Gelegenheit, weil ein bisschen auf diese KI-
Sache zu blicken, zurückzublicken, vorauszublicken, weil wir zwar immer wieder
hier Entwicklungen in der Netzpolitik und in der KI behandeln,
aber noch nicht so die gelegenen oder ich glaube, Zeit ist,
jetzt mal ein bisschen zu schauen, was ist das eigentlich für eine Technologie, die es da gibt?
Was macht sie aus und wie wird sie eventuell das Netz und die Gesellschaften beeinträchtigen?
Oder beeinflussen, formen oder herausfordern.
Ja, und wie soll man dazu stehen auch? Und das sind ja, glaube ich,
auch Fragen, die sich wirklich viele stellen derzeit.
Also nahezu alle. Also selten so ein Technologiethema erlebt,
vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von Internet,
wo es auf einmal unmittelbar alle betraf, aber vor allem unmittelbar alle so beschäftigt hat.
Und vielleicht ist es sogar hier noch mehr als bei anderen Sachen.
Ich würde sagen, es ist mehr, weil beim Internet gibt es ja schon Leute,
das hatten wir auch vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten in der Sendung,
die Eisenharte Offliner sind und die das jetzt einfach noch aussitzen.
Bis es ausfällt oder so.
Es gibt sicherlich auch bei Eisenharten Nicht-Intelligenzler,
die das jetzt auch aussetzen.
Okay, also wir haben eine Technologie. Du hast das hier in der Sendung ja auch
schon mehrmals dargestellt, was das Besondere jetzt eigentlich am Computer ist.
Wir hatten vorher eine Welt, in der wir,
Unsere Regeln formuliert haben in Programmen und den Computer diese Regeln haben anwenden lassen.
Dann haben wir immer komplexere Strukturen geschaffen, Programme,
Umgebungen, Datenumgebungen, dass das Thema Fehler in unseren Logiken ein großes wurde.
Dass wir also so komplexe Programme geschaffen haben, dass wir mitunter Jahrzehnte
damit beschäftigt sind, darin alle Fehler zu finden.
Aber das waren immer ein endlicher Satz an Regeln, der da zur Anwendung kam,
den Menschen geschrieben haben, der in seiner Komplexität vielleicht schnell
das Verständnis eines einzelnen Menschen in seiner Gänze schon übertraf.
Aber wir können in einem jeden Programm sagen, hier ist die Regel und die muss
anders oder die führt hier zu einem Fehler.
Wir haben mit der KI nun eine Technologie,
die aus potenziell chaotischen Daten großer Menge Regeln deduzieren kann,
also ableiten kann, indem sie versucht,
sich den in diesen Daten verborgenen Regeln am besten anzupassen und möglichst das zu reproduzieren,
was da drin ist, ohne dabei notwendigerweise die Regeln explizit zu machen.
Wir brauchen also für ein Problem, das wir mit KI gut lösen können, drei Dinge.
Daten in großer Menge, die möglichst gut gelabelt sind.
Wir brauchen darin nicht triviale Zusammenhänge, Weil die trivialen Zusammenhänge,
die können wir mit einfachen Regeln ergründen.
Und wir brauchen irgendein Gütekriterium, mit dem wir entscheiden können,
ob eine Lösung richtig oder falsch oder noch besser, eine Lösung besser als die andere ist.
Und wenn wir diese drei Dinge haben, große Menge Daten,
nicht triviale Zusammenhänge und eine Möglichkeit, die Güte einer Lösung zu
evaluieren, dann haben wir ein Problem, was für KI generell geeignet ist.
Hätten wir die Daten nicht in großer Menge, haben wir nicht genug Lernmaterial,
ist der Zusammenhang trivial, machen wir es mit einfacher Mathematik.
Und wenn wir kein Evaluationskriterium haben, kein Gütekriterium,
bei dem wir der KI zurückmelden können, das war jetzt gut oder besser oder schlechter
als das andere, dann kann sie nicht lernen.
Diese drei Dinge brauchen wir also und dann können wir eine Technologie mit
massenhaft Daten füttern und ihr das Feedback geben und sie passt sich automatisch an.
Das heißt, die Intelligenz ist nicht wirklich in dem Ergebnis,
also in der Antwort, die wir auf unsere Frage bekommen, sondern Intelligenz
ist eigentlich das Lernen.
Auch beim Menschen ja so.
Nichts, was sich nicht weiter entwickelt, adaptieren und lernen kann,
würden wir als intelligent bezeichnen. Entsprechend sagen wir auch, das ist Smart Home.
Da bin ich ja schlauer. Ja, stimmt. Weil du das Smart Home programmiert hast,
dass es irgendwie die den Rollladen runter macht, wenn der Vorhang aufgeht.
Und deswegen ist das Smart Home jetzt dumm.
Aber es kann halt nicht automatisch lernen.
Und diese Technologie haben wir jetzt. Was machen wir damit?
Wir geben dem Ding Datensätze, lassen Regeln deduzieren, von denen wir selber
nicht mehr wissen, was sie sind, dass dieses Ding auch nicht mehr explizit machen kann.
Und dann lassen wir es dieses deduzierte Wissen anwenden.
Und meistens tun wir uns dann freuen, weil es sogar jetzt mit uns spricht.
Und diese Technologie wenden wir jetzt möglichst auf alles Mögliche an, gerade,
primär auf viele Daten und stellen fest, keine Ahnung, das kann jetzt sprechen,
das hat so eine Wikipedia,
die snackt so ein Modell dann irgendwie an einem Vormittag durch und weiß einfach
alles, was da drin steht, kann nicht nur einzelnes Wissen darin,
zitieren, sondern kann auch Bezüge zwischen diesem Wissen darstellen und da
ist schon was wirklich Irres entstanden.
Kann man sich übrigens, ach hier, von Jannis auch CCC-Vorträge anschauen,
von Jannis Quer und auch von anderen.
Wir haben das auf dem Kongress und auf dem Camp von den unterschiedlichsten,
Expertinnen und Experten dieses Phänomen beleuchten lassen.
Und damit gehen wir jetzt auf die Mainscheid los.
Mhm.
Ja, also es ist wirklich bemerkenswert und es ist vor allem auch bemerkenswert,
wie schnell die Entwicklung nach wie vor ist.
Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt ungefähr so zwei Jahre der akuten öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung, glaube ich, durch. Zähle ich richtig?
Und Leute, die, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen mehr schon die Nase im Wind hatten,
verfolgen das vielleicht so seit fünf Jahren, dass so diese ersten Durchbrüche
sich wirklich angedeutet haben.
Also man hat ja einige Fortschritte erzielt.
Machine Learning, was ja hier die technische Basis ist,
hat schon vor längerer Zeit einfachere Dinge ermöglicht, sodass, was weiß ich,
in deinem Fotoalbum konntest du auf einmal nach Motorrad suchen und ohne dass du es eingegeben hast.
Tauchen auf einmal Fotos auf, wo auch ein Motorrad drin ist.
Weil diese ganzen einfachen Bilderkennungsalgorithmen schon sehr früh,
also Algorithmus, vielleicht das falsche Wort,
also diese Machine Learning Technologien, die halt auf so etwas angewendet wurden,
das hat schon relativ früh gute Ergebnisse erzielt.
Aber das eigentliche, der heilige Gral bei der ganzen Forschung der künstlichen
Intelligenz, die jetzt so 75 Jahre alt ist ungefähr,
war ja eigentlich dieses Sprache, menschliche Sprache verstehen und so der Benchmark
war so ein bisschen, man merkt nicht mehr, dass man mit dem Computer redet,
weil der ganze Dialog so flüssig abläuft.
Es gab ja so frühe Werke, wie dieses Elisa-Programm, was das so eher durch ein
paar Tricks schon mal versucht hat.
Und Leute sind auch schon damals ein bisschen drauf reingefallen,
auf dieses so, ja, einfach mal mit einer Gegenfrage antworten,
wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß und so weiter.
Das war natürlich noch kein echtes Verstehen, hat aber auch schon mal gezeigt,
wie wenig ich es manchmal brauche, um einen auch schon glauben zu lassen,
man hätte es mit Intelligenz zu tun.
Nur durch dieses intensive Machine Learning und vor allem durch das Steigern
dieser Datenmenge immer mehr Daten heranziehen.
Das Internet kam dazu, das Internet ist extrem gewachsen, unheimlich Wikipedia, andere Datenquellen.
Auf einmal war so viel Zeug da, dass sich gezeigt hat, dass diese Algorithmen,
das habe ich schon wieder Algorithmus gesagt, dass diese Methodik.
Dazu führt, dass es auf einmal exponentiell alles viel besser funktioniert,
umso mehr Daten man heranzieht.
Also während sich am Anfang so ein Funktionieren abgezeichnet hat,
aber es noch große Schwankungen hatte, wurde es auf einmal super flexibel und
super powerful, wenn man erstmal so eine gewisse Datenmenge überschritten hat.
Und das hat natürlich dann dieses Rennen ausgelöst. Auf einmal war Sprache gelöst.
Auf einmal war so Übersetzen von der einen Sprache in die andere Sprache,
da redet heute schon fast keiner mehr drüber, dass so Computer auf einmal alles übersetzen können.
Ja, das sprengt immer noch meinen Kopf, weil das halt schon sehr klar zeigt, dass,
hier die Systeme, die technischen Systeme einen Prozess auf einmal automatisch
nachgebildet haben, der eben sonst nur in unseren Gehirnen entsteht und das
ist schon mal, sagen wir mal,
die erste irre Geschichte eigentlich in dieser ganzen,
Technologie. Ja, und jetzt sehen wir halt.
Dass immer noch mehr kommt. Eso solo puede hacerlo la inteligencia artificial.
So einfach ist das.
Das kann nur künstliche Intelligenz.
Ja, aber das ist, denke ich, muss man immer wieder auch sagen,
so was hat KI jemals für uns getan.
Und auf einmal haben wir den Babelfisch erfunden.
Der auch damals schon in der Vorhersage nicht als besonders gute Idee in die
Geschichte der Menschheit eingegangen ist.
Aber natürlich eine Billion-Dollar-Idea war.
Und so entsteht jetzt der Hype-Cycle. Alle wollen mitmachen,
alle wollen investieren.
Und es wird jetzt natürlich gesucht nach dem.
Und ja, nach der Möglichkeit, damit große Dinge zu lösen.
Und interessanterweise, da gibt es dann viele Naysayer und Kritiker und so,
die dann so am Rande sitzen und sagen, ja, das kann ja alles viel besser,
das ist alles ein Papagei hier und so.
Aber mit dieser Technologie wollt ihr hier meinen Job ersetzen als Customer
Support Mitarbeiter für ein mittelständisches Unternehmen.
Das hat ja gar kein Spezialwissen von der Technologie, über die ich hier spreche.
Und dann lässt das Ding mal irgendwie ein Ei kochen und danach kann es halt
dieses Wissen aus einem Manual sehr, sehr gut wiedergeben.
Gleichzeitig sehen wir den Aktienkurs von Nvidia, der natürlich irgendwie skyrocketed,
wie man so schön sagt, seit vielen Jahren.
Weil man einen unglaublichen Bedarf an der Lern- und Anwendungshardware prognostiziert.
Dann bricht alles zusammen, weil die Chinesen sagen, guck mal hier,
wir haben das auf sanktionierte Althardware mit sehr viel weniger Aufwand hinbekommen, was Gutes zu bauen.
Dann steigt der Kurs wieder, weil man sagt, ja meine Güte, jetzt können wir
noch viel mehr machen, weil wir exponentielle Verbesserungen von KI wahrnehmen.
Und irgendwo auf diesem Hype-Cycle bewegen wir uns jetzt mit einem im weitesten
Teilen der Gesellschaft so
verbreiteten Gedanken, ja cool, dann mache ich das halt demnächst mit KI.
Dann lasse ich mir meine E-Mails freundlicher machen oder übersetzen.
Vielleicht schreibe ich bessere Schriftstücke schneller oder vielleicht programmiere
ich mit dieser Sache, was ja glaube ich das ist, was du am meisten anwendest, Tim.
Dass du KI als Supporter in der Programmierung.
Ja, das ist einfach, also da machen sich glaube ich auch viele Leute noch gar
keine Vorstellung, was das für ein Game Changer ist.
Also das ist wirklich krass.
Also da finde ich überhaupt gar keine Worte für.
Das ist einfach so irre. Also viele veräppeln das ja auch schnell und tun es
ab so mit ja, wenn die, immer so dieses Bild mit jemand, der keine Ahnung hat,
kann jetzt programmieren.
Das geht natürlich schief, weil man.
Schon in diesem Namen Assistent steckt ja drin, dass du eben auch noch eine
eigene Kompetenz mitführen musst.
Von daher sind diese Systeme tatsächlich am nützlichsten für Leute,
die ohnehin schon ein bisschen was drauf haben.
Und man wird nicht unmittelbar abgelöst, aber es ist natürlich so,
dass wir mehr Player sehen werden,
die mit AI-Assistenten auf einmal so totalen Turbo anschmeißen können.
Das merkt man gerade bei der Programmierung schnell.
Also wenn man mal so rumfragt, unter anderem Programmierern,
die so das ernsthaft betreiben.
Alle machen da ihre Schritte, weil es einfach Prozesse vereinfacht,
die vorher zeitintensiv waren,
aber die nicht die eigentliche Programmierarbeit so sehr geprägt haben.
Also dieses Kreative, dieses ich muss mir jetzt wirklich, ich muss jetzt das
Big Picture liefern und ich muss irgendwie ein Systemdesign finden,
in dem eine Lösung für ein bestimmtes Problem sich abbildet,
das da musste man 90% der Zeit noch mit Gerüstbau verbringen,
um überhaupt erstmal die Voraussetzungen zu schaffen,
diese Ideen dann wirklich auch einzuleiten.
Aber mit diesen AI Coding Assistance fällt sehr viel von diesem Gerüstbau einfach weg.
Und man kann schnell Ergebnisse erzielen, schaut drüber, sagt,
okay, passt, läuft so. Man kann das Eigentliche vornehmen und das wird wirklich eine Menge ändern.
Also das, wofür man vorher Mitarbeiter brauchte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Mitarbeiter da immer so geholfen haben, weil das ist… Nee.
Eben nicht.
Und ja, ich meine, schlechte Software haben wir ja nun auch schon genug gehabt.
Ich meine, das führt ja hier, sagen wir mal, die Hälfte unserer Sendungen sind.
Irgendwie fehlerhafte Systeme, die nicht ordentlich ihre Security überdacht
haben, wo das ganze Systemdesign nicht ist,
wo einfach nur fahrlässig gehandelt wurde oder wo einfach der ganze Prozess völlig verkackt ist.
Gerade wenn es so staatliche Dienstleistungen und so weiter betrifft,
wo man einfach immer wieder auf Software stößt, die einfach,
unnötig kompliziert und clumsy ist und sowas kann man sich jetzt vielleicht
mal ein bisschen abschütteln hoffe ich.
Vielleicht in dem Kontext nur nochmal kurz, warum wird ausgerechnet das Programmieren
so schnell von einer KI verarbeitet und abgenommen?
Naja, Programmierer haben seit jeher mit Computern gearbeitet und haben dort
ihren Code gespeichert,
kommentiert und üblicherweise auch in Versionierungssystemen nachgehalten.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt so etwas wie GitHub oder so als Datenbasis hast oder
andere Softwareprojekte, dann haben die nicht nur die Dimension,
dass du sie von oben nach unten lesen kannst und die Kommentare.
Sondern dass du in den, die Älteren von uns erinnern sich vielleicht an Subversion
oder sowas, aber eigentlich heutzutage alles mit Git, dass du in einem Repository
auch die zeitliche Dimension hast.
Wo dann nicht nur der Code kommentiert ist, sondern auch, welches Feature ein
spezifischer Commit jetzt gerade, welches Problem der gelöst hat,
welche Verbesserung herbeigeführt hat.
Das heißt, das ordentliche Arbeiten der Programmiererinnen hat auch eine perfekte
Datenbasis zum Anlernen einer künstlichen Intelligenz geschaffen.
Und deswegen kannst du, du hast halt hier viel Daten,
weil das Ergebnis Daten sind und du hast außerdem noch iterative Verbesserungen
und damit natürlich einen komplexen Datensatz mit Evaluationskriterien und einer klaren Bewertung,
ist was besser geworden oder nicht.
Und damit natürlich eine sehr gute Datenbasis für so ein neuronales Modell.
Und nicht nur aus der Datenbasis heraus, sondern du hast es ja beim Poemieren
auch mit formalen Sprachen zu tun, die dann auch überprüft und übersetzt werden.
Das heißt, wenn irgendeine Änderung von einem Compiler, der das dann in laufendem
Code übersetzen soll, einfach Fehler festgestellt werden, gibt es dann eben
für die AIs ja auch diese Rückmeldung, dieses nee, so geht es nicht.
Das heißt, die Dinger können sich selber verbessern.
Wir hatten ja auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, über die ersten Systeme,
als man noch versucht hat, Schach und dann Go vor allem zu spielen.
AlphaGo war glaube ich das erste System, was sich quasi selbst trainiert hat,
indem es eben einfach die ganze Zeit mit sich selbst Go gespielt hat und dabei
permanent ja immer die Belohnung gab mit, das hat zum Erfolg geführt,
das hat nicht zum Erfolg geführt.
Und beim Programmieren ist es halt ein bisschen ähnlich,
dass die Systeme sich halt hier selber pimpen können und das werden wir sicherlich
in Zukunft noch häufiger sehen, dass man einfach die Modelle sich gegenseitig trainieren lässt.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen, in welchen anderen Bereichen gibt es vielleicht
noch nicht ganz so viele Daten und werden jetzt Daten gesammelt.
Ich finde, diese Programmierung ist auch ein Beispiel für, sagen wir mal,
spezialisierte Modelle.
Da gibt es dann, was weiß ich, so ein, keine Ahnung, Modell für C-Code, für C-Sharp.
Du kennst dich da besser aus.
Diese weniger auf einzelne Programmiersprachen optimiert, sondern eher auf Programmieren als solches.
Was da alles dazu beiträgt, kann ich nicht beantworten, aber es gibt ein paar
Modelle, also das sind auch alles Large Language Models, die eben besonders
geeignet sind und auch als solche,
bekannt gegeben werden, dass sie fürs Programmieren besonders gut sind.
Aber man kann sich mit denen auch unterhalten?
Jaja, also Claude Sonnet ist so ein ganz normaler LLM, damit kannst du einfach
eine ganz normale Konversation führen, also dieser Claude Desktop,
das ist ja quasi so die Alternative von Anthropic, alle kennen halt ChatGPT und die Apps,
Claude ist halt im Prinzip dasselbe von Anthropic und das Modell des Populärs
ist halt dieses Sonnet-Modell, was einfach sehr gut trainiert wurde für Programmierung.
Und das macht derzeit, würde ich auch sagen, den Großteil des Marktes aus,
aber diese Anteile können sich sehr schnell verschieben.
Also auch Google hat da natürlich was im Game, auch OpenAI, also wer da die
Nase vorn hat, das kann sich sehr schnell ändern und da ist noch sehr viel Bewegung drin.
Was ich aber auch noch hinzufügen möchte,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das da ausdrücken soll, aber,
Aber man kriegt da schon, also der Grad an Verständnis, den man mit diesen Modellen
hat für die Aufgaben, die man lösen möchte beim Programmieren,
ist schon wirklich irre.
Also es ist einfach wirklich krass. Man kann jetzt wirklich...
Ein Projekt damit starten, indem man sich vielleicht erstmal eine halbe Stunde
mit diesem Modell über die Ziele einigt und sich einfach Ideen liefern lässt
und die dann durchspricht und dann sagt so,
nee, das würde ich immer gerne nicht so machen, ich möchte mich gerne mehr darauf konzentrieren.
Und man kann also permanent seine Ideen immer wieder refinen,
neu bearbeiten oder wie man so schön sagt, refaktorieren, also immer wieder
sozusagen auf ein anderes Gedankenmodell umstellen,
bis einem das dann gefällt und dann mit diesen Plänen losmarschieren.
Und ich habe halt einfach wirklich langsam so den Eindruck,
dass das, ich will es nicht Bewusstsein sagen, aber dass da einfach diese Intelligenz,
die sich darin abbildet, die ist so krass,
dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich rede einfach mit jemandem, der das Programmieren
als solches wirklich verstanden hat.
Und ich denke, das muss man an dieser Stelle auch einfach mal sagen, hat es ja auch.
Ja, also wenn wir das jetzt mal auf eine andere Ebene heben,
das wird ja den Beruf der Programmiererin dann doch sehr nachhaltig verändern,
weil in einer Welt,
in der Menschen in einem Cloud Sonnet eine Ansprechpartnerin haben,
die zu jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit perfekt mit ihnen über ihr Code und ihr Projekt
reden kann und mit der sie das entwickeln kann,
Das wird sicherlich schon dazu führen, dass sich diese Leute potenziell fragen
werden, warum soll ich hier eigentlich noch Leute anstellen und denen das beibringen?
Und wenn das nicht mehr passiert, stellt sich die Frage, wer wird denn dann
irgendwann noch in der Lage sein, besser als dieses Ding zu trainieren?
Oder spielen die dann auch alle wie AlphaGo gegen sich programmieren und werden
einfach nur immer besser? und die menschliche Fähigkeit wird obsolet in diesem Bereich.
Ja, also wir werden es auch erleben, dass diese Systeme sich halt selber ausdenken,
welche Software man schreiben könnte und das dann auch einfach alleine tun.
Ja, gegen uns.
Oder für uns.
Aber das, was sich da herannaht in nur so kurzer Zeit, ist auf jeden Fall,
und das ist jetzt auch nur in diesem einen Bereich, den Tim da jetzt mal geschildert hat,
in vielen anderen Bereichen wird das sicherlich dann zu ähnlichen fürchterlichen
Effekten führen oder erschreckenden Aspekten.
Klana ist ja ein Unternehmen, wo der CEO sehr früh angekündigt hat,
gesagt hat alles klar, wir halbieren jetzt hier die Belegschaft und ich will das alles von,
KI machen lassen ich denke, der hat dann noch relativ früh, wenn ich mich nicht
täusche oder auch andere Unternehmen, haben dann nochmal einen Schritt zurück
gemacht und gesagt okay,
scheint so zu sein, dass wir das jetzt nicht hinkriegen, die alle sofort durch ein Chatbot zu ersetzen.
Wir brauchen die dann doch wieder, aber ich denke, man kann hier sehr klar davon
ausgehen, dass die Menschen, die jetzt noch arbeiten, jetzt halt ein Modell
trainieren und dass das Setup geschaffen wurde.
Oder alles klar, wir bezahlen euch hier noch pro Stunde für eure Arbeit.
Aber alles, was hier rein und raus geht, das wird in so ein Modell gefüttert.
Und da arbeitet ihr quasi nur daran, so ein Modell, also noch mehr Lernmaterial
für so ein Modell zu schaffen, damit ihr hier irgendwann wegautomatisiert seid.
Und diese Automatisierung, das, was wir jetzt so langsam den Weg gegangen sind
von der KI als Supporterin für Tim, der seine Programme da bastelt,
Und hin zu einer kommerziellen kapitalistischen Nutzung,
wo Tim jetzt schon als Beispiel in der Lage ist,
Programme zu schreiben, die er sonst alleine nicht in der Lage gewesen wäre
und damit auch eventuell hier ein Output liefern kann,
dass vielleicht einen traditionellen durchschnittlichen Programmierer übertrifft
und bald vielleicht auch das Output eines traditionellen Unternehmens übertrifft.
Der Schritt ist nicht mehr weit, dass der Tim da halt auch nicht mehr sitzen muss.
Du arbeitest gerade an deiner eigenen Abschaffung.
Davor habe ich zum Beispiel überhaupt gar keine Angst, also auch nicht durch
automatisch generierte Podcasts.
Ja, ah, das ist, das finde ich einen spannenden Exkurs, den wir an der Stelle
mal machen können, wo wir jetzt sagen,
kreatives schaffen, da hatte ich auch mit der Jago da kurz in dem Podcast drüber gesprochen, wo.
Dann ja Texte geschrieben werden. Es wurde dann ein Experiment besprochen,
da sollten Leute Aufsätze schreiben und die einen haben die halt mit Chat-GPT
gemacht oder durften Chat-GPT zur Hilfe nehmen und die anderen mussten es selber machen.
Und in der wiederholten Anwendung wurde dann festgestellt, dass die mit Chat-GPT
generierten Aufsätze von Unabhängigen
dann als, ja, irgendwie dann am Ende liebloser wahrgenommen wurden.
Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher also wir haben ja schon vor einiger Zeit hier
über dieses mit KI generierte Bild gesprochen was bei Sotheby's dann irgendwie so einen hohen Wert,
erzielt hat in der Versteigerung ich habe sicherlich auch mal darüber gesprochen
dass hier Beethovens 10.
Symphonie, die ja nicht fertig gemacht hatte, die hatten sie dann irgendwie
mit einer KI fertig gemacht und aufgeführt Und das war trotzdem natürlich schön
und hat ja seine emotionale Wirkung trotzdem auf Menschen.
Und ich weiß wirklich nicht,
ob sich dieses, das ist von einem echten Menschen noch so lange als emotionales
Kriterium auch für uns halten wird. Wie blickst du darauf?
Und meinst du jetzt spezifisch den Kunstbereich?
Es gibt noch einen zweiten Bereich, den ich danach berühren würde.
Das wäre der Bereich Psychologie und Therapie. Aber lass uns vielleicht erstmal
in Schönheit schaffen. Also Hackerethik.
Man kann mit einem Computer Kunst und Schönheit schaffen.
Vielleicht ist das, der Computer kann Kunst und Schönheit schaffen.
Also ich meine, ein Kunstwerk, also natürlich ist das hervorragende Kunst,
wenn jemand das erste Mal mit KI so ein Kunstwerk erschafft,
weil dann war es halt neu.
Und Kunst, die Aufgabe von Kunst ist meiner Meinung nach auch immer das Neue,
mit dem Neuen zu spielen und sich neue Dinge einfallen zu lassen,
was man miteinander kombinieren kann.
Und das wird meiner Auffassung nach auch so bleiben,
weil das eben so die originäre Qualität des Menschen an der Stelle ist,
auch so eine Randomness zu generieren, die sich nicht unbedingt daran orientiert,
was die anderen Daten jetzt gesagt haben,
wie das zu sein hat, sondern wo einfach die neue Idee ja jenseits sich dessen
bewegt, wie es bisher immer war, sondern die ja im eigentlichen Sinne Neues,
also dass die Maschinen wirklich Neues produzieren können und nicht nur quasi
das intelligent nachäffen, was bisher schon getan wurde, das muss ich noch zeigen.
Okay, aber jetzt ist da sagst du jetzt Kunst, okay da ist aber auch schon irgendwie einen starken,
Kunstbegriff oder ein Kunstbegriff voller hoher Achtung für die Kunst Was ist
denn was runterstufen auf einfach nur kreativ Ist jetzt kein Kunst,
ist jetzt nicht Picasso aber.
Ich denke Kreativität.
Und Kunst.
Das steht im Zusammenhang also nicht exklusiv für Kunst,
Kunst ist schon eben, finde ich, ein kreativer Output, der eben auch nicht unbedingt
geleitet ist von irgendeinem klaren Ziel.
Also wo es nicht um Geld verdienen geht oder Dinge reparieren, normale Vorgänge.
Kunst kann immer für sich dastehen und reflektiert diese Welt und bringt neue Ideen.
Ich meine, man hat es ja auch in der Literatur, die Science-Fiction ist sozusagen
immer vorneweg und liefert uns eigentlich so ein bisschen auch den Weg in die Zukunft.
Also alles, was entsteht, war auch irgendwann mal Science-Fiction und war zu
dem Zeitpunkt im Prinzip Kunst.
Also auch ein Science-Fiction-Buch ist in dem Sinne für mich halt Kunst und
so eine Urform kreativen Denkens.
Natürlich kannst du dir jetzt von so einem Large-Language-Model auch irgendeinen
Science-Fiction-Roman zusammenschreiben, aber ob der wirklich mit bahnbrechenden
Ideen daherkommt, das werden wir noch sehen.
Ich will es nicht auslesen.
Okay, aber dann lass uns trotzdem mal bei der kreativen Leistung bleiben.
Also eine Geschichte, ein Musikstück, nicht notwendigerweise Kunst.
Wirst du das immer abwertend? Glaubst du, dass das niemals auf dich die emotionale
Wirkung haben wird, die etwas von einem Menschen Geschaffenes haben wird?
Glaubst du, dass es nie die Qualität erreichen kann, die etwas von einem Menschen Geschaffenes hat?
Es kann die Qualität erreichen, definitiv. Also ich habe jetzt schon irgendwie,
es ging hier gerade irgendwie dieses erste,
es gab so ein Album rum, was komplett KI erzeugt wurde und wo einfach niemand mehr sagen würde,
Das klingt jetzt nicht wirklich wie so eine Aufnahme aus den 50er Jahren,
wo irgendwie so eine Band Jazz spielt.
Also das ist schon möglich, das zu erzeugen.
Wir werden natürlich als Menschen auch immer den Bezug zu Menschen haben wollen.
Für uns ist bei Musik ist es ja auch die Identifikation oder die Bezugnahme
auf einen Künstler gehört ja
auch mit dazu wir haben auch oft das schon gehabt, früher so Milli Vanilli,
die sozusagen das Objekt waren in der Öffentlichkeit mit ihrer Musik wo sich
dann später rausgestellt hat, das war dann doch wieder nur alles von Frank Farian,
teilweise auch gesungen und sie waren eigentlich gar nicht die Schöpfer dieser Musik.
Du hast auch oft auch schon so Bands, die ja sozusagen wirklich nur noch Darbieter
und Verkäufer eigentlich einer bestimmten Musik sind, die vollständig von anderen
Leuten produziert wird.
Funktioniert dann,
Teilweise eben auch schon. Da können wir uns jetzt ein bisschen verrennen, glaube ich.
Wir kommen auch ein bisschen weiter weg von dem, was vielleicht KI ist.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Bezug zu realen Personen weiterhin eine große Rolle spielen wird,
auch wenn wir jetzt erstmal eine Phase erleben werden, wo everything KI generiert
sein wird und bis wir es dann nicht mehr ertragen können.
Das finde ich dann, okay, was ich mich tatsächlich, also wenn wir mal diesen
Gedanken, der Bezug zu einem Menschen, wenn wir den jetzt mal weiter gehen.
Psychotherapie. Nehmen wir mal Psychotherapie als Beispiel.
Sehr enge, tiefe, emotionale Verbindung, Thematik, die man mit Menschen eingehen muss.
Und jetzt hast du auf der, wenn du jetzt die Frage stellst, wird denn so eine
KI jemals eine Therapeutin ersetzen können?
Oder wird dieses Verhältnis dem Computer immer fernbleiben, dass er es nie erreichen kann?
Und ich glaube, die Antwort ist hier super einfach. Therapien funktionieren
üblicherweise nach wissenschaftlichen Manualen, also wenn es vernünftige Therapien sind.
Das heißt, der Mensch, der da mit dir die Therapie macht, geht eh nur in einen Modus.
Und muss außerdem sehr sensibel für deine Emotionen sein und sehr gut seine
eigenen unter Kontrolle haben.
Das schafft der Mensch nur so und so viele Stunden am Tag, professionell.
Er wird dabei Schwankungen in seiner Leistungsfähigkeit haben.
Durch eigene Belastung, viel gegessen, wenig gegessen, letzte Nacht gesoffen,
gerade vom Partner oder von der Partnerin getrennt.
Oder einfach letzte Sitzung war mit irgendeinem Arsch, mit dem komme ich nicht zurecht.
Das heißt, da hast du eine unglaubliche Schwankung, auch in der Passung zwischen,
Therapeutin und Patientin und so.
Und jetzt kannst du sagen, alles klar, red einfach mal hier mit diesem Modell.
Das hat die Stimme, die du haben willst. Wenn die Stimme dir nicht gefällt,
stellst du den ein bisschen höher, ein bisschen tiefer.
Du kannst ihn einstellen. Heute brauche ich jemanden, der sehr einfühlsam ist
oder ein bisschen strenger.
Er ist einfach ein Slider und du kannst mit dem so viele Therapiestunden machen, wie du willst.
Ich finde das und ist auch jederzeit da, ist halt nicht gerade ein Termin,
wenn du in einer Notsituation bist und gerade einen therapeutischen Bezug brauchst.
Finde ich absolut naheliegend, dass das, was da vielleicht an menschlicher Nähe
durch einen echten Menschen noch vielleicht eine Rolle spielt,
auf jeden Fall durch die Verfügbarkeit, Dauer, Professionalität,
auf jeden Fall wettgemacht wird.
Es mag sein, dass sich dann besonders reiche Menschen noch so einen eigenen Shrink leisten.
Der hat ein Büro oder so eine Couch und der kommt vorbei oder so.
Der ist gut angezogen oder die.
Den leisten wir uns noch so. Aber die Menge der Bevölkerung,
natürlich wirst du die mit so einer KI dann da irgendwie abklären.
Und findest du das? Wie findest du das?
Ich,
und ist diese Idee im Raum, wie geht es mir damit?
Du fühlst dich in deiner Sache sehr...
Das ist für mich jetzt erstmal ohne Bewertung eine Betrachtung der Situation,
oder eine Betrachtung, wo ich denke, wie sich das entwickeln wird.
Wenn wir uns die katastrophale Unterversorgung der Menschen mit psychotherapeutischem Support anschauen,
dann denke ich, dass das ein positiver Ausblick ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Du darfst auch nicht vergessen, eine Therapeutin kann auch ebenfalls eine Patientin ablehnen.
Da hast du natürlich auch noch mal einen selektiven Bias.
Wenn die Leute, die sich zur Therapeutin ausbilden lassen, Die finden dann ihre
eigenen Schwerpunkte und vielleicht liegen die nicht da, wo der Bedarf ist bei den Menschen.
Potenziell bestimmte Bilder sind sehr viel einfacher zu therapieren oder sehr
viel angenehmer für dich vielleicht als andere.
Das kann man alles durch den Einsatz von neuronalen Modellen auf jeden Fall
die Versorgungslage verbessern.
Da wird natürlich auch schnell die Frage kommen, sind dann diese Empfehlungen auch die richtigen?
Wir haben ja durchaus auch die Möglichkeit, dass solche,
Systeme durch das falsche Training oder durch einen falsch geführten Dialog
auch schnell in einen ganz anderen Geisteszustand versetzt werden können.
Wir hatten ganz zu Beginn, als alle noch so fröhlich am Experimentieren waren
und keiner was Böses vermutet hat, hat ja Microsoft mal dieses Thai-Experiment
auf Twitter gestartet, so eine AI, so hallo, ich bin's,
redet mal mit mir, ich lerne dabei.
Und es hat glaube ich 24 Stunden gebraucht und die freundliche Thai-virtuelle
Person wurde zum Vollnazi.
Ja,
da würde ich im Prinzip, dem würde ich entgegenhalten, ein bisschen wie autonomes Fahren.
Ja, wir sagen, das betrachten wir jetzt als Schwierigkeit, wenn da computergesteuerte
Autos rumfahren und nachher jemanden überfahren.
Mag sein, dass das ein Problem ist.
Aktuell werden die Leute von besoffenen Menschen überfahren,
die irgendwie Autorennen fahren wollen oder beim Rechtsabbiegen nicht gucken,
was eine der Basic-Regeln ist.
Wenn wir am Ende feststellen, dass computergesteuerte Fahrzeuge unterm Strich
weniger Leute töten, dann ist das erstmal gut.
Und dann werden wir uns sehr wohl damit anfreunden und werden uns genauso daran
gewöhnen, dass uns ein Roboter das Kind überfahren hat, wie wir uns daran gewöhnen,
dass ein Betrunkener ein Kind überfahren hat.
Nämlich überhaupt nicht im konkreten Fall.
Aber als Gesellschaft nehmen wir das ja problemlos hin, dass das passiert.
Und ich denke, dass da eben in der großen Zahl die Entwicklung dann doch hingehen würde.
Der Einzelfall ist immer konkret und schmerzhaft und die unterm Strich sagen,
es ist halt besser so als andersrum.
Tausend Leute konnten gerettet werden durch automatisierte Psychotherapie die
zwei, drei, die zum vollständigen Durchdrehen gebracht wurden.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würden heute überleg mal, wie viele Psychotherapien
nicht mit dem gewünschten Ergebnis enden das wird dann heute,
das ist dann eben das wird dann so hingenommen,
ah ja, konnten wir nicht helfen keine Ahnung, wir haben wirklich viel Psychotherapie
gemacht hat ja wenig funktioniert, der ist immer noch depressiv für die Person.
Ja, kannst du nichts machen, muss irgendwas anderes sein.
Also ich überziehe das jetzt mal.
Also heute verzeihen wir ja auch sehr viele Fehler.
Ich denke, wenn es um technische Lösungen geht, die sozusagen vollautomatisiert
sind, dann gibt es irgendwie auch einen höheren Wunsch, das sozusagen perfekt zu machen.
Während wir bei Menschen halt irgendwie immer ein Auge zudrücken,
weil wir eben auch wissen, dass wir eben nicht perfekt sein können.
Bei der Technik hat man zumindest die Hoffnung, dass sie irgendwie perfekt funktionieren
kann, auch wenn das eigentlich auch immer regelmäßig nicht stattfindet.
Also meine These wäre, bei vielen Aufgaben, die wir Menschen,
die wir nur Menschen zutrauen, stellen diese Menschen einer KI keine besonders hohe Hürde.
Naja Ich sag das gerade sehr also absichtlich natürlich auch mal ein bisschen,
provokativ und ich freue mich auch, dass wir da so in diese Diskussion eintreten
Mir wäre es auch lieber, wenn das menschliche Schaffen noch lange,
wichtiger bleibt und auch seinen Wert erhält.
Ich fürchte nur, dass es halt so viel Nachfrage gibt und so viel Bedarf an Dingen,
dass selbst wenn KI nur die 80-Prozent-Lösung ist, dass sie eben doch in der Regel helfen wird.
Schau mal an, wie viele... Also es gibt doch schon vor vielen Jahren gab es
zum Beispiel diesen Film Hör, wo ein Mann sich in so ein KI im Ohr,
oder was ist das? Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wo diese KI ist.
Auf seinem Computer.
Auf seinem Computer. Verliebt er sich. Und dann, das war gar nicht vorgesehen,
dass er sich da rein verliebt, haben sie irgendwie die KI war zu emotional eingestellt,
scheiße, so war nicht vorgesehen.
Produktfehler, ja kacke, jetzt hat er sich da rein verliebt.
Katastrophale Konsequenzen für den Menschen. Gleichzeitig haben wir,
was in anderen Ländern inzwischen als Epidemie anerkannt ist, der Einsamkeit,
dass viele Menschen allein sind und keine nicht genug emotionalen Austausch
mit anderen Menschen haben.
Dadurch, dass es quasi als Krankheitssymptom anerkannt, dass du vereinsamst
mit den fürchterlichen Konsequenzen, die das auf deine Emotionen,
auf deine Intelligenz, auf deinen Input hat.
Kannst du potenziell mal versuchen, damit zu lösen.
Und da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die Leute sagen, nee,
nee, nee, ich will lieber hier ohne Menschen vereinsamen, als mit einer KI mich
unterhalten und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Input bekommen.
Weiß ich nicht, wie lange da noch dieser Stolz der Menschheit erhalten bleibt.
Also ich meine, solche Fälle hat es auch schon gegeben, auch tragische,
also wo sich so Verliebtheitssituationen abgespielt haben, die teilweise dann
aber auch zum Selbstmord geführt haben, aus Verzweiflung.
Das sind auch keine schönen Geschichten. Ich habe Schwierigkeiten,
mich da überhaupt so zu äußern, weil für mich das, ich weiß nicht,
könntest du dich in den KI verdienen?
Ich glaube, wir sind der Technik irgendwie zu nah,
als dass wir auch nur auf die Idee kommen würden, dass da was ist,
was sich unserer wirklich, wirklich annimmt.
Wir würden, glaube ich, dieses Misstrauen gegenüber der Technik,
das würden wir nie loswerden.
Das mag sein. Ich würde, also sag nie, nie. Und ich glaube,
also verlieben ist so ein Thema. Da spielen ja auch andere Faktoren,
pheromonische Faktoren und sowas eine Rolle. Aber,
überleg mal, wie viele Menschen über lange Zeiträume,
Fernbeziehungen, Brieffreundschaften und sonstiges führen. Das wäre jetzt nicht das...
Und da halt auch Beziehungen herstellen. Schau dir an, dass du... Das wäre ein breites,
Phänomen, dieses, wie fehlt gerade der Name, Love Scamming oder was,
wo im Prinzip irgendwelche Leute,
quasi, also irgendwelche Typen, 20 Tinder-Profile von hübschen afrikanischen
oder asiatischen Frauen unterhalten und es schaffen, dass sich,
in der Regel dann einsame ältere Männer,
in sie verlieben. Da gibt es ein paar Fotos.
Weil sie denken, es handelt sich um wirkliche Menschen.
Ja, aber auch, weil sie ja offenbar einen hohen Bedarf nach Nähe haben,
der für dessen Befriedigung sich oder für dessen Stillung sich jetzt so ein
Tinder-Profil eignet, was ein Mensch, den man noch nie gesehen hat.
Die sagen ja alle, ich habe mich in diese Frau verliebt. Ich will die jetzt
nach Hasse nicht gesehen holen, die
muss jetzt irgendwie fliegen von dem Flughafen, wo sie sagt, nach hier.
Also das funktioniert ja. Ich will nur sagen, es ist in dem Menschen drin,
sich in etwas, was man nicht anfassen kann, was nach allem menschlichen Ermessen
nur ein paar Zeilen Text in der Dating-App sind, zu verlieben.
Klar, solange die Hoffnung da ist, dass es eben nicht nur ein paar Zeilen in der Dating-App sind.
Das wird sicherlich jetzt noch krasser werden, wenn auch die Videogeneratoren
sich in demselben Maße verbessern, wie es derzeit schon den Anschein macht.
Ja, dass also solche Echtzeit,
Videotelefonate auf einmal so real werden, dass du Schwierigkeiten hast,
das noch zu unterscheiden.
Da sind wir ja auch teilweise schon, es gab ja schon mehrfach auch solche Scams
in irgendwelchen Videokonferenzen, wo also,
Realtime-Avatare zum Einsatz kamen, die sich ausgegeben haben,
als wäre es jetzt hier irgendwie Chef von Unternehmen und dann gab es halt Anweisungen,
die dann ausgeführt wurden und dann war das Geld überwiesen.
Weil Chef hat das ja gesagt in der Videokonferenz.
In der WhatsApp-Audio-Nachricht oder so.
Also ich will da niemandem in die Parade fahren, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
dass einzelne dieser Fälle,
Vielleicht auch nur sehr günstige Ausrede waren.
Das kann auch sein. Aber das ist immer genau mein Problem.
Man weiß schon wieder mal überhaupt nicht mehr und es kommt schnell dieser Ersatz,
was soll man noch glauben? Wem kann man noch trauen?
Und das, da werden wir sicherlich noch drauf kommen, dieses große,
dieses, wie soll ich sagen, diese Zurückhaltung und auch diese Angst vor dieser
ganzen AI ist, die wir wahrnehmen,
finde ich eben auch teilweise berechtigt, weil es einfach das generelle Gefühl
des Misstrauens noch weiter verstärkt.
Und das ist glaube ich wahrscheinlich überhaupt das größte Problem,
was wir derzeit in der Gesellschaft haben.
Dass die Leute einfach das Vertrauen in alles verlieren.
In Beziehungen, in den Staat, in Institutionen aller Art.
Und die natürlich dann schnell auch ausgenutzt werden von Leuten,
die sagen, ja, hier haben wir dir doch schon immer gesagt, wähl uns,
dann wird wieder alles gut.
Ja, alles so wie früher, wo es viel besser war.
Gut, jetzt haben wir die kreative, menschliche Komponente, den Realitätsverlust.
Wir müssen uns vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen vor den, und ich sehe,
ich bin mal wieder echt erstaunt, wie viele Bezüge wir hier zur Hackerethik haben.
Die Hackerethik, alle Informationen müssen frei sein. Du hast die Bezüge zu
Misstrauerautoritäten, fördere Dezentralisierung.
Man kann mit einem Computer Kunst und Schönheit schaffen, Computer können dein
Leben zum Besseren verändern,
aber auch Mülle nicht in den Daten anderer Leute, öffentliche Daten nutzen,
private Daten schützen, hat schon seine Bezüge hier.
Der Gedanke, der Misstraue, Autoritäten fördere Dezentralisierung,
der spielt für mich bei dieser ganzen KI-Geschichte auch nochmal eine große
Rolle. Ich will mal ein Beispiel geben.
Von uns beiden hier regelmäßig besprochen, Google. Wer will denn noch Suche?
Also Suche muss ja wohl echt mal vorbei sein.
Menschen kommen doch nicht ins Internet, um das zu navigieren und sich irgendwie
die zehn besten Seiten anzeigen zu lassen, sondern sie wollen entweder die Antwort
auf eine Frage finden oder etwas kaufen.
Und das, du willst die Antwort auf eine Frage finden, dafür hat Google dir bis
vor kurzem einfach zehn Seiten gegeben, dann konntest du mal gucken, ob das da steht.
Und wenn du was kaufen wolltest, haben sie dir eine Anzeige geschaltet und damit
ihr Geld verdient, dass du das dann gekauft hast.
Es beginnt nun langsam auch bei Google, Perplexity waren früher da dass du nur
noch eine Frage stellst, eine Antwort bekommst und ein paar Quellenangaben dazu,
stellt sich natürlich schon die Frage wer will denn warum soll ich in 10 Jahren
noch eine Webseite machen um irgendeine KI zu füttern,
Besucht doch eh keiner mehr. Wer weiß, ob in zehn Jahren noch jemand einen Browser hat.
Also schon denkbar, dass sich das Ökosystem Internet sehr fundamental ändert.
Oh ja, also vor allem was so Finanzierungsmodelle betrifft, wird sich nochmal
einiges im Kreis drehen.
Da bin ich auch mal gespannt, wie lange das noch dauert, bis,
diese Modelle noch Geld kosten und dass es da keinen werbefinanzierten Free-Tier gibt.
Das denke ich, wird auch nicht mehr so lange dauern.
Oder auch, dass dann so ein Modell darauf optimiert wird, eben nicht,
dass es dir die besten Antworten gibt, sondern dass es dir am meisten verkauft.
So ein Portemonnaie-Trainer.
So eine Art Chat-GPT,
Basic ChatGPT Free Premium funktioniert nur weiter, wenn du jetzt hier dieses
Paar Schuhe auch kaufst, dann kriegst du noch mal 10 extra Fragen,
was du noch kaufen sollst, gratis.
Ich meinte jetzt weniger die Geschäftsmodelle dieser AI-Betreiber als vielmehr
die Geschäftsmodelle von allen anderen Teilnehmern im Internet.
Die sind nämlich durchaus in Gefahr auf die verschiedensten Arten und Weisen.
Oh, du meinst zum Beispiel Anbieter jetzt von Nachrichtenseiten oder was. Ja.
Ja.
Auch, wir hatten das ja hier vor kurzem behandelt, diese Diskussionen zwischen,
New York oder diese rechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen zwischen New York Times
und Open AI über die Nutzung ihrer Inhalte und so.
Ja, und auch generell die Frage, ich meine, auf der einen Seite,
wollen wir irgendwie keine Werbung mehr überall angezeigt bekommen.
Werbung ist aber dann doch das, was diese ganzen Nachrichtensysteme am Leben erhält, schon immer.
Also auch früher haben ja Zeitungen, gut teilweise auch noch durch den Verkauf,
aber eben vor allem durch die geschalteten Anzeigen und dieses Bereitstellen
einer Öffentlichkeit, die sozusagen so ein Medium ja hat,
aber wenn jetzt das Wissen quasi überall eingesammelt und nur noch an einzelnen
Stellen herauskanalisiert wird, dann gibt es diese ganzen Öffentlichkeiten auf
einmal gar nicht mehr, die man verkaufen kann.
Und das ist für viele ein Problem,
auch im Softwarebereich sind auch so Open-Source-Finanzierungen,
die sich teilweise eben durch Webseiten, wo Dokumentation,
Support angeboten wird,
refinanziert haben.
Also damit sozusagen den wesentlichen Betreibern bestimmter Libraries,
Systeme, Frameworks, Programme damit sozusagen Geld zugespielt haben.
Auch das ist natürlich durch diese allwissenden Systeme, die Dokumentation automatisch
bereitstellen, werden also auch diese Eyeballs nicht mehr generiert.
Und von daher ist das schon ein Problem und man muss sich eben fragen,
wie sehr wird sich das Internet dadurch jetzt nochmal weiter zentralisieren,
obwohl wir ja schon heute das Gefühl haben, dass es das schon weitgehend getan hat.
Jetzt kann es sein, dass da auch nochmal der Turbo eingeschaltet wird.
Ja, und dann stellt sich auch die Frage, wer generiert denn dann,
also auf welchem Weg und warum werden überhaupt noch neue Inhalte für diese Systeme generiert, ne?
Also auch das hat wieder viele Dimensionen.
Also erstmal, wo soll sozusagen der eigentliche neue Content herkommen,
wenn er nicht mehr von Menschen erschafft wird, sondern nur noch von den Maschinen.
Also irgendwann hat sich das
dann ja auch ausgelernt. Jetzt haben wir natürlich auch noch das Problem,
dass jetzt schon mit AI noch auf Basis des aktuell funktionierenden Aufmerksamkeitsprinzips
des Internet dadurch natürlich Geld gemacht werden soll,
indem man so Flooding the Zone mäßig so viel Slop generiert.
Es gibt da ganz viele Webseiten und es werden quasi Nachrichtenmedien simuliert
aus AI-generierten Content,
die dann wiederum die Quelle sind für die nächste AI und alle erzählen sich
aber eigentlich nur noch Unsinn, weil es eigentlich nur noch im Hintergrund darum geht,
die aktuellen Bezahlkanäle abzugreifen und schnell die Hand aufzuhalten. Mac Money Fast.
Dabei kann aber durchaus sein, dass sich eben dieses System selber zerstört.
Und zwar sowohl unsere wirtschaftlichen Systeme existierender realer Webseiten
und der damit verbundenen Organisationen und Akteure.
Als eben auch, dass die AI-Systeme sich damit selbst zerstören,
weil sie gar keinen richtigen Content mehr wahrnehmen, sondern eigentlich sich selber fressen.
So ein bisschen wie mit BSE,
wo die Kühe dann auf einmal diese Kreuzfeld-Jakob-Krankheit,
diesen Rinderwahnsinn entwickelt haben,
weil sie sich sozusagen selbst gefressen haben, weil sie halt Kuhfleisch irgendwie
zu essen bekommen haben.
Und ein ähnliches Drama steht natürlich jetzt auch diesen Systemen bevor,
die sich jetzt verbessern wollen, indem sie immer von allem immer mehr haben,
aber das Ganze immer mehr, was rumliegt, sind sie selbst und damit fressen sie
sich selber auf und dann funktioniert das Ganze vielleicht auch nicht mehr.
Da wird sich dann die Weitsicht von Google will eat itself von übermorgen nochmal,
also da kannst du dann wirklich mal Weitsicht erkennen.
Das sind die Künstler, die wirklich die Zukunft vorher sagen, habe ich doch gesagt.
Ja, also die Frage, gibt es denn dann, also das finde ich auch zum Beispiel sehr interessant.
Sehr interessant. Also okay, Menschheit geht hin, erfindet Computer,
fängt an Daten zu machen.
Also sagt, wir speichern jetzt was und dann bauen wir immer größere Speichersysteme,
immer bessere Computer, verdaten alles.
Fitness-Tracker, wahrscheinlich die Apple Watch hat 4 GB,
irgendwelchen Quatsch verdartet. Wir erfassen alles, was noch nicht erfasst
wurde, muss erfasst werden.
Gibt einen Scanner, wir müssen jetzt die Bibliothek hier durchscannen und so.
Wir müssen alles erfassen und alles.
Mach mal noch ein Foto, mach mal noch ein Foto, bis die AI auf einmal Videos machen kann.
Was ich spannend finde, ist, wie viel gibt es eigentlich?
Wie viele Daten gibt es noch, die noch nicht erfasst wurden?
Du erkennst ja schon, dass die großen KI-Betreiber sich so Daten kaufen.
Also Reddit zum Beispiel als ein Nischenforum oder als das Forum der Nischen.
Der Wert von Reddit sind die menschlichen Beiträge, die dort stattgefunden haben
und weiter stattfinden. Der Wert von Reddit ist, dass man damit eine KI trainieren kann.
Und daraufhin haben die das Ding ja auch sehr früh dann eben umgebaut oder umentwickelt
vom Geschäftsmodell her.
Das heißt, es findet jetzt schon dieser Wettlauf statt, wo man noch Daten bekommen kann.
Und ich frage mich, fängt der gerade an oder ist der bald vorbei,
weil alle Daten dann verkauft wurden und erfasst wurden?
Ja, also das ist ein echtes Problem. Wo kommt dieses Mehr an Daten jetzt her?
Also an realen und vor allem an menschlichem Input.
Also Reddit ist deshalb ein Wert, weil da noch echte Menschen diskutieren.
In gewisser Hinsicht. Das ist auch weg.
Automatik.
Ja, da bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht so sicher, ob das sozusagen auch noch alles
echte Menschen sind, die da diskutieren.
Das wäre für mich echt ein Traum also wenn ich einfach nicht mehr diskutieren
müsste, sondern einfach so den Chat-GPT-Premium einfach so bam,
ich baller dich jetzt weg, ich hau jetzt, ich werfe einen Zwanni und deine,
komische Free-KI da die wird jetzt an dem Boden,
diskutiert in diesem Forum der Flame-War ist meiner, ich werfe einfach nur Geld
nach das würde ich als Entlastung empfinden man.
Merkt aber auf jeden Fall,
diese unbegrenzte Expansion, von der glaube ich derzeit noch viele träumen und
die ja so ein bisschen im Raum steht mit so, wo soll das alles noch führen,
die Modelle werden immer besser,
kann durchaus sein, dass wir da schnell an neue Grenzen, dass wir sehen,
dass die an neue Grenzen stoßen.
Wo jetzt noch gar nicht so klar ist, wie die dann dann überwunden werden können
und ob die auch so ohne weiteres überwunden werden können.
Ich glaube, da hat noch keiner so eine richtig gute Antwort drauf.
Und es muss auch natürlich die Frage gestellt werden, ist die derzeit dominante
Technologie von Large Language Models auch noch beliebig.
Verbesserungsfähig? Oder braucht es noch mal einen weiteren großen technologischen
Durchbruch jenseits der Large
Language Models, um eben wirklich zuverlässiges Reasoning zu bekommen,
was ja so ein Schlagwort ist derzeit, dass Modelle jetzt,
Reasoning-Modelle sind, weil sie sozusagen dann über jeden ihrer Schritte nochmal
mit sich selber nochmal nachdenken und so, aber es sind eigentlich alles immer
nur so Kaskaden von LLMs, die über LLMs nachdenken.
Das ist auch ein interessanter Gedanke ist, dass diese ganzen Systeme eigentlich
die ganze Zeit nur mit sich selbst beschäftigen, um irgendwie sich zu verbessern, aber dabei dann den,
Kontakt mit der realen Welt auch irgendwie zurücklassen.
Ich bin, also es gibt ja dann noch diesen Pfad, dass man denkt,
okay, ja, die spezifischen Datenmengen, also okay, das Ding kann reden, ist in Ordnung,
aber was ist jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwelche Medizinforschung,
Gene erforschen oder so, dass man da jetzt noch Daten reinwirft,
um da verborgene Zusammenhänge drin zu finden und dann machen wir Forschung, Forschung mit KI,
dass jetzt vielleicht diese,
Fähigkeit, dass das Ding sprechen kann,
sich am Ende als das für die Menschheit in ihrer Abschaffung noch am wenigsten
beeindruckende Feature war.
Dass das Ding dann irgendwann keine Ahnung,
was es noch zu erforschen gibt oder zu entwickeln oder zu generieren gibt,
dass da dann der Irrsinn erst noch kommt und dass wir uns auf dieses Sprechen
so viel eingebildet haben,
und auf die Manipulation unseres Verhaltens und sich das aber quasi noch als
eine der leichtesten Übungen herausstellt.
Also ich meine, was Medizin ist, hast du das Stichwort mal genannt,
was Medizin betrifft und speziell
die Genforschung oder sagen wir mal die Proteinforschung vor allem angeht,
da erwarte ich ehrlich gesagt auch die größten, den größten Nutzen von der ganzen
Technologie derzeit, weil ich glaube,
da ist die Technologie gerade wirklich in der Lage.
Dinge zu entschlüsseln, die uns bisher komplett verborgen geblieben sind.
Du hast es ja eingangs so schön erklärt.
KI ist die Technologie, die es schafft, aus diffusen Daten,
sagen wir mal frei übersetzt, Schlüsse zu Die dann im Idealfall auch überprüfbar
sind und man hat das ja gesehen mit diesem AlphaFold-Projekt,
sicherlich eine der interessantesten Aktionen von Google,
die ja mal eben diese komplette Proteinforschung innerhalb weniger Jahre komplett
auf den Kopf gestellt hat.
Also man hat ewige Zeit probiert, Voraussagen darüber zu machen,
okay, welcher genetische Code wird jetzt in, was kommt da für ein Protein-Bayer raus?
Also wer da vielleicht in der Terminologie-Welt nicht ganz so fest ist,
also Proteine sind ja sozusagen der wichtigste Baustein unseres Lebens.
Also wir sind voll mit diesen Proteinen und die Proteinen sind im Prinzip alles so kleine Maschinen.
Und sehr komplex eben aus diesen...
Aminosäuren zusammengesetzt und wenn man halt sagt, okay, hier ist ein Bauplan
für so ein Protein, dann hat man zwar so eine lange Kette, die man beschreiben
kann, aber man wusste eben nicht,
wenn diese Kette dann zusammengebaut wird,
wie faltet sich das dann real dreidimensional zusammen und was entsteht daraus für ein Mechanismus?
Und wenn man das eben gut vorhersagen kann, dann kann man eben vielleicht den
Körper selber einen Protein bauen lassen, der dann eben Krebszellen bekämpft.
Das ist ja so im Wesentlichen der heilige Gral, wo ja auch viele jetzt gerade am Forschen sind.
Es war halt bisher einfach überhaupt kaum möglich, mit Software diese Vorhersage
auch nur so annähernd zu machen.
Es gab da so einen Wettbewerb, was gerade nicht wieder heißt,
aber wo dann sozusagen einmal im Jahr immer alle Systeme verglichen wurden und
man kam halt irgendwie nie über irgendeinen bestimmten Prozentsatz hinaus,
weiß nicht genau, wo der lag, 30, 40 Prozent oder so.
Und dann kam halt irgendwie Alpha Fold und das Ganze ging dann KI-basiert und
mittlerweile sind wir eben schon weit über 90 Prozent und es ist halt jetzt
wirklich vorhersagbar.
Das heißt, da ist gerade ein Prozess gestartet worden, wo ich davon ausgehe,
dass wir in den nächsten 5 bis 10 Jahren enorme Fortschritte sehen werden im
medizinischen Bereich.
Und es gibt sicherlich noch sehr viele andere Bereiche der Wissenschaft,
die auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise da vorangebracht werden können,
wie zum Beispiel auch die ganze Wissenschaft an sich, weil all das Wissen liegt
ja mehr oder weniger formal in diesen Papers da.
Und natürlich bemühen sich jetzt auch KI-Systeme, das Wissen aus diesen Papers
herauszuziehen und weiterzuentwickeln, was ja eigentlich so die typische wissenschaftliche Methode auch ist.
Nur, dass wir natürlich jetzt auch wieder die Kriegsgewinnler haben wollen,
die dann eben ihre Papers von der KI schreiben lassen und das geht alles gar
nicht, aber sie wollen den Ruhm haben, in irgendeinem Paper veröffentlicht zu
werden und damit dann auch wieder den Brunnen vergiften.
Ich bin da ein bisschen abgeschweift jetzt gerade.
Also spannend auf jeden Fall, was wir über das Leben der Menschen und der Tiere
und der Pflanzen und ihrer Krankheiten und Verletzlichkeiten in der Biologie
im weitesten Sinne da gibt es auf jeden Fall noch einiges an Wissen,
was wir noch nicht haben bin mal gespannt,
ob die Daten dafür,
da sind oder ob wir noch viel mehr vermessen müssen, noch viel mehr von uns
erfassen müssen, um Korrelationen festzustellen.
Mal gucken, was da noch kommt. Aber ich würde dir zustimmen,
dass in diesem Bereich sicherlich mithilfe dieser großen,
Korrelationsanalysen noch einiges hoffentlich für uns getan wird.
Löst meine Probleme, KI!
Die,
eine weitere Betrachtung, die ich bei all dem immer noch sehe,
ist halt Zentralisierung.
Wir haben gerade gesagt, so Google, die KI als das Interface zur Interaktion zur Menschheit.
Wir sind bis ins Verlieben gegangen.
Wovon wir nicht gesprochen haben, ist, dass wir potenziell in Zukunft irgendwie
mehrere KIs nutzen würden, sondern wir gehen eigentlich schon davon aus,
dass wir halt eine haben werden, wo wir potenziell sogar ein bisschen das Risiko
gehen, dass wir uns in sie verlieben.
Vielleicht bis als Lebensende mit ihr glücklich werden.
Bis das unser Tod uns scheidet. Und die KI jemandem anderen,
nur noch von vielen anderen geliebt wird.
Nein, tatsächlich erkennen wir ja jetzt schon, dass.
Also Beispiele. Microsoft hat in seine M365 Services schon direkt jetzt diesen Co-Piloten eingebaut.
Das heißt, sie warten nicht darauf, dass irgendjemand anders macht oder so,
sondern das wird jetzt einfach ausgerollt. das ist Teil der Subscription oder
kann man eben sich mit dazu klicken oder so, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie der ein Pricing-Modell ist.
Das heißt, Microsoft ist von einem Unternehmen, das MS-DOS auf Disketten als Produkt verkauft hat,
zu einem Unternehmen geworden, das Microsoft Windows auf CD-ROMs verkauft hat,
zu einem Unternehmen geworden,
was Microsoft Windows Lizenzen verkauft und Updates unterzieht,
was ein Office-Produkt wieder als Kiste im Mediamarkt verkauft hat, zu etwas,
was jetzt letztendlich eine Subscription für ein Ökosystem ist,
wo du ein Unternehmen drin abbildest.
Der Personal Computer dient nur noch als Fenster in diese Cloud-Welt.
Die Dateien auf deinem eigenen Computer haben zu folgen, ist eigentlich ein
vermessener Anspruch, der immer unsinniger wird.
Und demnächst hast du dann eben auch die KI in dem Sharepoint lauern,
die aus deiner Arbeit lernt und die immer mehr der Prozesse,
die für dein Unternehmen potenziell relevant sind.
Natürlich auch abbilden soll und wird.
Und wenn wir vielleicht vor ein paar Jahren von einem Login-Effekt gesprochen
haben, weil du jetzt irgendwie dein Unternehmen mit Excel und Microsoft machst
und jetzt nicht mehr wechseln kannst auf was weiß ich, Open Office oder was auch immer,
das die freie Welt noch für dich bereithält.
Wirst du vielleicht in zehn Jahren mit der KI irgendeines Unternehmens,
was du als Service, und das ist das Entscheidende, die sind alle von einem Software,
ist in den letzten zehn Jahren ungefähr, würde ich sagen,
von einem Produkt zu einem Service geworden.
Dir wird nicht mehr unbedingt angeboten, dass du jetzt, also ja,
für so ein Nintendo, für so eine Switch kannst du dir ein Spiel kaufen.
Einmalig. Aber vieles andere wird dir doch als Subscription angeboten.
Hier die, wie heißt das? Photoshop.
Früher als Produkt, kann sich ja keiner leisten.
600 Euro kostet so ein Photoshop. Wenn der Illustrator und so dabei haben,
2.000, 3.000 Euro, das kriegst du ja nie.
Er hat ja keine Privatperson gehabt. heute 10 Euro, zack, geklickt.
Ich zahle seit Jahren 10 Euro im Monat für Photoshop, nutze das nicht.
Am Ende haben die mehr Geld von mir bekommen, als sie jemals hätten von mir erwarten können.
Es ist ein Service, den ich subscribe. Es ist bei mir so, ich könnte die Photoshop.
Subscription kündigen, wenn mein Vater nicht ab und zu mal Photoshop bräuchte.
Aber da ist also schon der Login jetzt. Ich riskiere hier unstimmig mit meinem
Vater, wenn ich jetzt da aufhöre, Adobe Geld nachzuwerfen.
Wenn ich im Unternehmen bin, ist der Login-Effekt klar, dass ich da eigentlich nicht mehr rauskomme.
Und wenn die jetzt auch noch eine KI da ausrollen, dann wird das demnächst nicht
mehr nur der Login-Effekt für die Kollaboration sein, sondern potenziell mein
ganzes Geschäftsmodell sich bei denen abbilden.
Aber ich würde sogar sagen, in dem Fall ist der Login-Effekt vielleicht gar nicht mal so groß, weil.
Der Login ist ja immer noch, um mal beim Photoshop-Beispiel zu bleiben,
es ist ja eigentlich die Kernfunktion dieser Software und ihre Datenformate,
die hier dich dabei hält.
Auch wenn es natürlich Alternativen gibt zu Photoshop, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Sache.
Der KI-Teil selber wiederum wird allerdings von wirklich sehr vielen anderen auch dargeboten.
Und es gibt auch in zunehmendem Maße einen, ich will jetzt nicht Open Source
sagen, aber ein offeneres Nutzungsmodell.
Es gibt ja tonnenweise Systeme, also zum Beispiel das Lama von Meta ist ja frei verfügbar.
Ja, man kann sich das fertig trainierte Modell herunterladen und theoretisch
auf seinem eigenen Computer laufen lassen.
Nur der Nutzen, den wir heute aus den großen Systemen online ziehen.
Der entsteht ja auch dadurch, dass die erstmal sehr große Modelle haben,
die kann ich mir auch herunterladen, aber dann eben, wenn ich eine Anfrage mache,
dass eben auch auf so viele Computer gleichzeitig verteilt wird, diese Anfrage,
dass die Antwort auch sehr schnell da ist.
Weil eben sehr viel Speicher erforderlich ist für einen kurzen Moment.
Und für so einen kurzen Moment kaufe ich mir ja nicht irgendwie einen Computer
für 15.000 Euro, der das dann in halbwegs acceptabler Zeit für mich vielleicht
auch noch machen könnte.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass diese Modelle ja auch am laufenden Meter aktualisiert
werden und immer auf dem neuesten Stand sind.
Aber grundsätzlich sind die Leistungen, die diese ganzen Modelle und Anbieter
machen, sehr vergleichbar.
Man kann relativ easy sagen, ich mache das jetzt mit Chat-GPT,
ach das Ergebnis hat mir jetzt nicht gefallen, dann mache ich das jetzt mal mit Gemini,
passt jetzt auch nicht so richtig, dann gehe ich mal dahin und perspektivisch,
vielleicht unterschätzen wir das auch noch,
kann es sehr wohl sein, dass wir auch mit den Leistungen der Computer schnell
jetzt in so einen Bereich kommen, wo moderne,
trainierte Systeme good enough sind und dann eben mal nicht unbedingt mehr bei
einem zentralen Dienst.
Sich diese Dienstleistung abholen muss, weil die dann eben wiederum von den
Computern auch durchaus auch lokal angefertigt werden zu können.
Das ist ein bisschen unklar, aber könnte sein.
Du hast natürlich jetzt mit Photoshop dir das Beispiel genommen.
Klar, da wird dann ein Bild generiert oder was.
Das ist irgendwie einfacher...
Sich da vorzustellen, dass man da in eine Konkurrenzsituation geht.
Aber nimm mal ein Microsoft-Beispiel. Du hast jetzt,
ich benutze das nicht, aber ich lese das dann, hast du irgendwie Microsoft Cloud,
das benutze ich sogar, dann kannst du irgendwie kollaborieren und so.
Deine Dokumente sind in einem Sharepoint. Jetzt rollt Microsoft aus,
der Sharepoint hat jetzt AI.
Und dieses, schreib mal, du meinst doch nicht ernsthaft, dass du in einem Jahr
noch Chats-GPT sagen musst, schreib mal bitte eine freundliche E-Mail und die
dann in Outlook-Copy-Pasten musst,
wo du dann oben noch mitpastest, hier ist eine freundliche E-Mail ohne die Schimpfworte
an das Arschloch, mit dem du hier schmeicheln möchtest.
Das ist ja dann alles vorbei. Das heißt, die Frage ist, garantiert wird das integriert.
Apple hat es ja jetzt mit diesem Apple Intelligence schon getan, dass sie das machen.
Und entsprechend wird Microsoft, so wie du heute mit deinem Cloud deine Programme schreibst,
wirst du potenziell mit Microsoft dann Word dann andere Prozesse abbilden.
Und es gibt ja Unternehmen, die tatsächlich Prozesse damit abbilden,
nicht einzelne Arbeitsergebnisse. Also Beispiel, schreib mal bitte eine Rechnung.
Ja, Rechnungsnummer. Das wäre jetzt eine triviale Aufgabe, dass so ein System,
Microsoft Cloud-System dann sagt, das ist übrigens die Rechnung mit der Nummer
so und so und wahrscheinlich soll die an den Kunden so und so gehen,
der bei dir im Projekt-Tracker ja jetzt gerade auf Abschlussphase ist.
Du hast ja übrigens auch gestern die Mail geschickt mit dem Endergebnis an den
Kunden und übrigens soll ich das mal direkt noch in der Buchhaltung machen und
dann hast du Prozesse nicht nur abgebildet in diesem System,
sondern vielleicht auch allein in diesem System etabliert.
Und dann hast du ja einen ganz anderen Login in beispielsweise jetzt hier so
eine Microsoft Cloud, in der eine ganze Reihe Unternehmen, sei es mit Excel,
sei es mit Word, ihre Geschäftsprozesse abbilden.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht mehr und nicht signifikant anders,
als du heute schon deinen Login mit SAP hast, wo genau diese Geschäftsprozesse
auch schon abgebildet sind.
Also es fügt dem jetzt nicht eine neue Qualität hinzu, es ziehen nur alle mit, jetzt auch mit AI.
Aber das macht nicht wirklich was anderes daraus.
Ich, jein. Also du hast recht. Erstmal nicht.
Der Login-Effekt ist der gleiche. Aber aktuell bilden Leute mit SAP Geschäftsprozesse ab.
Noch nicht SAP für die Leute Geschäftsprozesse.
Das ist ja das, was dann der nächste Schritt sein wird.
Das Beispiel, was ich gerade nannte, war, heute musst du noch selber sagen,
verbinde bitte diese Datenbank mit der und wenn hier in dem Excel jemand einträgt,
ich habe heute gearbeitet,
dann bucht das auf den Kunden. Das musst du selber bauen.
Klassisches Beispiel. Und kriegt auch nie einer fertig hin. Klassisches Beispiel
von komplexen Daten mit dann am Ende doch relativ klaren Zusammenhängen,
an denen ein bisschen Abfolgen sind.
So was wie, wolltest du nicht mal diesem Kunden jetzt eine Rechnung schreiben,
das ist ein Schritt davon entfernt, dass sie auch einfach rausgeht.
Und dann hättest du natürlich einen anderen Login-Effekt, als dass du alle deine
Daten da reingetragen hast. sondern auch, dass das Ding jetzt.
Eine aktive Rolle in der Abbildung deiner Geschäftsprozesse spielt.
Und du potenziell sagst, naja, okay, wenn ich hier nochmal rauswandere,
wenn ich jetzt alle meine Daten aus diesem Sharepoint nehme und versuche die
bei SAP oder bei sonst was, dann
muss ich ja damit rechnen, dass keine Rechnungen mehr geschickt werden.
Also weißt du, was ich meine? Dass du das,
Nicht nur der einzelne Arbeitsschritt und deine Daten sich dort abbilden,
sondern Prozesse, die abgenommen wurden und die quasi Geisel sind deiner Subscription.
Ja, aber auch genau diese, in Anführungsstrichen, intelligenten Prozesse können
dann wiederum von anderen Systemen auch sehr viel einfacher übernommen werden,
weil ich halt das sozusagen einfach da genauso automatisieren kann.
Also am Ende sind diese, die Agenten, ich sag es mal anders,
die Agenten sind derzeit noch wichtiger als die AI selbst.
Also wenn wir von solchen Systemen reden mit, ich benutze die AI,
um den Request des Menschen zu verstehen oder um Prozesse, die ich gerne abgebildet
sehen möchte, zu beschreiben und dann wird die von dem System ausgeführt.
Das nennt man ja Tool Use derzeit in dieser AI-Sprache.
Das ist auch beim Programmieren so. Ich kann halt sagen, ja,
hier ist ein blöder Fehler.
Guck doch mal, wie der Code vor einer Woche aussah. Dann benutzt er das Tool
Git und guckt dann eben in der Historie nach und dann wird eben wirklich so eine mechanische,
also ein deterministisches System wird von der AI benutzt.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist eben auch die Automatisierung der Firma mit SAP
oder irgendwas Vergleichbarem genauso.
Das AI ist oben so ein Sahne-Layer obendrauf, der mich eben besser versteht,
wo ich eben ohne komplizierte User-Interfaces
einfach mit normaler Sprache beschreiben kann, was ich will.
Aber der eigentliche Wert geht schon noch von dem Tool darunter aus.
Also ich bin da ein bisschen, sehe deinen Punkt.
Natürlich gibt es hier auch Login-Gefahren, aber ich sehe keine qualitativ anderen Gefahren als die,
die wir von dem Non-AI-Code derzeit auch schon haben und sehr viel davon hängt
derzeit auch vor allem von dem Non-AI-Code ab und weniger von dem AI-Code.
Also das würde mich jetzt nicht ganz so beunruhigen und ob jetzt die großen
Anbieter sich dauerhaft ihre Vorteile so erhalten können,
das wird glaube ich noch sehr von dem Innovationspace der nächsten Jahre abhängen,
weil ich einfach sehr viel mehr Disruptionspotenzial in dieser ganzen Entwicklung sehe,
dass neue Player auf einmal auf den Markt kommen.
Ich meine, von OpenAI haben wir alle vor fünf Jahren nichts gehört, nichts gewusst.
Und auf einmal reißen die aber an dem bestehenden System dann doch ganz erheblich mit dran.
Ob sie Erfolg haben werden, werden wir sehen, aber zumindest sind sie auf einmal
da und kamen mehr oder weniger aus dem Nichts.
Und ich denke, hier ist noch sehr viel Potenzial für weitere neue Player und
es muss sich nicht unbedingt das aktuelle System etablieren.
Also da freut mich dein seltener Optimismus. Ich denke, der Login ist heute schon da.
Und wie gesagt, dieses Geschäftsprozess abbilden würde ich da als das Paradebeispiel dafür sehen.
Du hast eh schon einen Login und jetzt wird der einfach noch,
auf die Weise verschärft, dass du eine ganze Menge nützlicher Funktionen hast,
dass du Agency bekommst in diesen in einfachen Geschäftsprozessen,
Optimierungsvorschläge anfangs kommen, irgendwann Optimierungen stattfinden
und ganze Bereiche mit denen man heute vielleicht noch Menschen beschäftigt,
weg optimiert werden als Teil einer Tool-Subscription.
Und jetzt gehst du jetzt, das Spannende ist, da, wo du gerade arbeitest,
da lieferst du die Daten für diese Automatisierung.
Da ist der Vorsprung. Und dann, wenn du die Subscription hast und dann noch
vielleicht dann bezahlst du eigentlich dafür, eine KI zu nutzen und gleichzeitig.
Sie zu verbessern. Ich glaube, das ist ein unschlagbares,
Modell für diese, ja, für die, fürs Geldverdienen, für Zentralisierung, für die.
Diese KI einerseits einer Breite an Menschen zur Verfügung zu stellen,
gleichzeitig aus der Breite der Daten, die sich da die Gesamtzeit ändern,
dafür zu sorgen, dass diese KI auch immer besser wird und gleichzeitig eine
kolossale Abhängigkeit zu führen.
Und ich sehe, wenn ich mir anschaue, wie locked in ich bin in dem Apple-Universum,
was nicht mehr passieren oder sagen wir mal so,
was nur unter Aufwendung großer Urlaube oder unbezahlter Urlaube möglich ist,
ist meine Flucht aus dem Apple-Ökosystem.
Und ich glaube, was für viele Unternehmen gar nicht mehr möglich ist,
schon ohne KI, ist irgendwie die Flucht aus dem Microsoft-Ökosystem.
Ich vermute, du unterschätzt die Bedeutung von Microsoft Office für Unternehmen und Unternehmen.
Das Potenzial der automatischen Abbildung und Optimierung der Prozesse, die sie damit spielen.
Das wäre meine Vermutung und das ist ein Privileg, weil du mit dieser Scheiße nichts zu tun hast.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe ja gesagt, der eigentliche Wert ist das Tool derzeit noch und dass
Office eine große Bedeutung hat, das ist jetzt für mich keine News.
Ich meine, ich benutze es kurz und lang nicht. Ich habe diesen Login nicht,
Aber es ist mir schon klar, dass die meisten natürlich bei Microsoft sehr verheiratet
sind und teilweise eben auch bei Apple, ganz klar, weil sie eben diese Tools machen.
Ich sage ja nur, AI ist derzeit für Microsoft eher eine Notwendigkeit, dass sie das einbauen,
weil die Technologie es eben anderen erlauben würde, auch mit weniger ausgeprägten
Tools einiges zu kompensieren durch eben solche Techniken.
Weil da eine neue Nachfrage entsteht und man quasi das User-Interface auf einmal
normale Sprache werden kann, beziehungsweise es sehr viel einfacher ist,
jetzt auch solche User-Interfaces bereitzustellen,
die eben Leuten da einen Migrationspfad aufmachen können.
Aber das müssen wir ja auch nicht weiter vertiefen, das wird sich dann zeigen.
Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, hier ist einfach viel in Bewegung derzeit und neue
Player haben durchaus eine Chance.
Ob die gewinnen werden, keine Ahnung, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine spannende Zeit.
Immer wenn man denkt, die Player im großen Spiel des Netzes und der Technologie
sind festgelegt auf die nächsten 30 Jahre,
stirbt einer oder kommt wieder ein Neuer mit rein, der die Regeln wieder neu schreibt.
Okay, sagen wir mal also nehmen wir an, da kommt ein Neuer und darf die Regeln
neu schreiben das mag sein, da gab es noch, also wäre ja schön wenn Microsoft
dann doch nochmal sein Ende findet, ja,
aber es wird einen neuen, also es wird,
eine weiter zentralisierte Welt werden, weil von allem, was wir jetzt gesprochen
haben wir reden da wenig,
wir reden da vielleicht von Potenzialen und so, wir reden vielleicht davon dass
jemand anders das Rennen macht Aber wir reden nicht davon, dass das in eine
Diversität und Heterogenität der Services, Interfaces,
Infrastrukturen und Beitragenden geht, sondern dass alles, von dem wir gesprochen
haben, geht in eine weitere Zentralisierung.
Ja,
stellt sich generell natürlich so ein bisschen die Frage, wer profitiert jetzt
eigentlich am meisten von diesen ganzen Bewegungen.
Und natürlich ist so Information Processing und Informationen,
diffuse Informationen verwerten das natürlich auch so klassische Geheimdiensttätigkeit, sag ich mal.
Es war schon immer die Aufgabe eines Geheimdienstes oder sagen wir mal eines
Nachrichtendienstes, um es etwas vorsichtiger auszudrücken.
Ein Nachrichtendienst soll aus diffusen Daten Intelligence erzeugen.
Informationsvorsprünge.
Ja, das ist das, was die Central Intelligence Agency im Wesentlichen macht.
Die hat überall ihre Nase drin und liest überall mit und schaut sich alles an
und hat ihre Kontakte und ihre Informanten und ihre Satellitensysteme und ihre
Quellen und all das läuft dann halt irgendwo zusammen.
Und dann versucht man aus diesem ganzen Datenfuß irgendwie relevante Informationen
herauszuziehen, mit denen man was anfangen kann.
Das ist sozusagen die Aufgabe eines Nachrichtendienstes.
Und es war schon immer so mit der Überwachung, dass die Ausbreitung von Überwachung,
wir haben ja glaube ich immer eine Weile lang auch geglaubt,
dass man irgendwie so mit moralischen Argumenten,
politischen Argumenten Überwachung aufhalten kann, aber eigentlich ist es nur eine Geldfrage.
In dem Moment, wo alles billiger wird, dann wird einfach,
Einfach der Regler ganz nach oben gedreht und gesagt, kostet ja nichts mehr,
können wir also hier maximal ausbauen.
Das haben wir mit Kameraüberwachung gesehen, generell mit der Überwachung des öffentlichen Raums.
Wir haben es im Internet gesehen. Ja, da hält man dann einfach mal sein Rohr
direkt an das große Internetrohr der Zixe,
der Internet-Exchanges ran und liest einfach mal alles mit und schreibt einfach
erstmal alles mit. Einfach erstmal wegschreiben.
Für irgendwas wird das schon gut sein. Was die Speicherhalte hergeben.
Ah, Festplatten sind noch billiger geworden, man kann noch mehr abspeichern,
beziehungsweise die Computer werden schneller, man kann noch mehr in Realtime
diese Daten bereits analysieren, man muss sie gar nicht mehr wegschreiben.
All diese ganzen Faktoren, die mit dem Fortschritt der Technologie kommen und
mit sinkenden Preisen führen mehr oder weniger automatisch dazu,
dass eben solche Auswertungen gemacht werden.
Und natürlich ist jetzt auch AI in diesem Machtspiel dann ganz vorneweg,
weil Datenanalyse ist schon irgendwie immer das Ding gewesen.
Der Klassiker ist ja so ein bisschen dieses IBM Watson. Ich habe da selber nie
mitgearbeitet und hatte das auch noch nie vor der Nase wirklich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal gesehen hast, aber das war ja schon früher immer
so ein bisschen dieses System, was dafür gemacht war, diffuse Daten zu analysieren.
Was weiß ich, man füttert das dann mit Banküberweisungen von ganz vielen Banken
und versucht irgendwie herauszubekommen, ob da irgendwelche Wischiwaschi.
Geldwäschesysteme am Start sind, sowas zum Beispiel. Und,
Und ganz klar, das sind natürlich Sachen, da ist eben die AI-Technologie,
das Machine Learning perfekt dafür.
Und deswegen sind, glaube ich, auch die Anbieter, die sich in diesem Tooling
jetzt spezialisieren, besonders weit vorne.
Wie zum Beispiel Herr Thiel, der windige Financier dieser ganzen Tech-Bubble,
mit seinem Palantir-Unternehmen, die Software herstellen, die irgendwie alle
Polizisten haben wollen.
Ja, bei uns regelmäßig behandelt,
eine Software zur Verbindung der Datenquellen auf die Polizei grundsätzlich Zugriff hat,
die aber, auch das ist ein Thema, was wir regelmäßig wiederholen,
nicht notwendigerweise gleiche Unique Identifiers haben.
Wir haben keine einheitliche Personen-Kennziffer in Deutschland und entsprechend
gibt es eine ganze Reihe Datenmengen, Datenbanken, die grundsätzlich dem Staat zur Verfügung stehen,
aber die zu meistern dem einzelnen Polizeimitarbeiter oder der Mitarbeiterin relativ schwer fällt.
Palantir ein Produkt, was genau das ermöglichen soll.
Uneinheitliche, wilde Datenbanken vielleicht ein bisschen fuzzy,
stochastisch zur Verbindung bringen und so die Möglichkeit bieten,
diesen Datenschatz und seine darin schlummernden Erkenntnisse einheitlich adressieren
und darin suchen zu können.
Das ist nur ein Beispiel, Peter Thiel, nun wirklich kein Demokrat,
ein bekennender Antidemokrat,
der sehr eigentümliche Ansichten und Ziele hat.
Und als derjenige klar bekannt ist, der J.D.
Vance den aktuellen US-Vizepräsidenten dort installiert hat.
Das ist ein Zögling von ihm. Und er hat dann irgendwie dafür gesorgt,
dass das der Vizepräsident von Donald Trump wurde.
Ja, obwohl eine ganze Menge Leute sich vorher sehr bemüht haben,
in diesen Arsch zu kriechen, hat der Peter Thiel das geschafft,
das zu positionieren und er verfolgt da sehr klare, konkrete Ziele.
Und naja, von dem kaufen wir jetzt unsere polizeilichen Überwachungssoftware. Nächstes Thema.
Ja, ich meine gut, man kauft ja nicht unbedingt gleich seine Lebenseinstellungen mit dazu.
Zeigt sich nur, dass also wirklich auch ein paar sehr windige Leute mit im Spiel sind.
Und auch Elon Musk, der ja auch nicht gerade den Popularitätswettbewerb gewonnen
hat in diesem Jahr, ist mit seinem,
Grog, also eine XAI heißt die Firma, Grog ist das Modell, was sie da produzieren,
mit dabei und es macht vor allem auch den Eindruck,
dass da auch diese wie soll man diese Leute überhaupt nennen, diese,
technlibertären Protofaschisten.
Ich glaube Technofaschisten Also ich finde das eine Verunglimpfung von Techno,
deswegen würde ich eher sagen Tech-Faschisten oder Tech-Bros.
Wie hat es die Anke Domscheit-Berg hat so einen wunderschönen Titel für ihren Vortrag bei der Fusion.
Jetzt ist das Programm ja öffentlich.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt ja auch daraus zitieren. Lass mich mal kurz schauen,
wo habe ich es denn? Nicht, dass ich das jetzt hier,
falsch zitiere. Eine Zukunft ohne digitale Monopole, Tech-Bro-Milliardäre und
ihre kapitalistische Kackscheißer.
Ja, Tech Pro. Genau, also diese Leute auf jeden Fall, die ja eine wirklich merkwürdige
Agenda verfolgen, die also sehr undemokratisch ist.
Die wollen ja ihre Freedom Cities haben, die wollen irgendwie entbunden sein
von diesem ganzen demokratischen Regelspiel,
die wollen einfach machen und das ist so ein bisschen auch einfach so eine Traumwelt
mit dem Recht des Stärkeren und sehr wenig Anderem.
Also wir haben auf jeden Fall wirklich ein sehr ausbaufähiges Verständnis des Begriffs Freiheit.
Der Begriff wird ja seit jeher von vielen Leuten sehr wild verzerrt in alle Richtungen.
Ja, sei es die Freiheit im Rahmen der Corona-Pandemie, sei es die Freiheit,
andere Menschen zu diskriminieren und fertig zu machen und das ist schon alles
sehr… Junge Freiheit zum Beispiel.
Ein sehr strapazierter Begriff.
Absolut.
Aber auch auf dieser sehr strapazierten Skala der Freiheit rangiert halt so
ein Peter Thiel wirklich…,
Auf einer stark verzerrten, am sehr stark verzerrten Meta-Ende nochmal, ja.
Genau, und dieser Traum von irgendwie so einer Singularität irgendwie,
also die sind ja wirklich in so einem fast religiösen Wahnzustand auch unterwegs
und da spielt halt AI irgendwie auch die ganze Zeit irgendwie eine Rolle.
Das ist so ihr Werkzeug für alles.
Mit diesem bekloppten Doge-Projekt, wo er nun Gott sei Dank rausgeschmissen
wurde, aber ich glaube, die Organisation gibt es immer noch.
Er hat seine Zeit da ja formal beendet.
Auf jeden Fall sind die da mit seinen ganzen jungen Hackern da reingerauscht,
haben irgendwie Daten des Staates gezogen ohne Ende, um das dann in ihre AI reinzuschmeißen.
Das ist so ein bisschen dieser Ansatz. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus.
Es gibt auch Leute, die das so als Werkzeug der Macht einsetzen.
Und das halte ich für ausgesprochen bedrohlich, diesen ganzen Prozess,
auch wenn man ihn natürlich nicht kontrollieren kann.
Und ja, alle werden das jetzt tun.
Vielleicht muss man auch noch mal über militärische Aspekte reden.
Ja, also die geopolitischen Abhängigkeiten, in die wir Europa ja ohnehin schon begeben.
Also schaut ihr an, also das Mobilfunknetz in Deutschland wird,
man kann mit eigenen europäischen Komponenten keinen...
Kein konkurrenzfähiges Mobilfunknetz mehr bauen.
Wir können Computer nicht bauen ohne starke Abhängigkeiten auf Taiwan.
USA bauen unter Anleitung von Elon Musk mit Starlink ein weltumspannendes Internet,
was sie sicherlich nicht machen, dass du und ich in unseren Wohnwagen am Wochenende
ein bisschen was runterladen können,
sondern was sie machen, damit sie weltweit ihre Drohnen unter Kontrolle haben,
ohne auf das Internet eines anderen sich verlassen zu müssen.
Wir haben Microsoft, das zumindest in der westlichen Welt auf jeden Fall die
Enterprise-IT dominiert.
Wir haben Google, was lange Zeit unser Fenster zur Realität da draußen war.
Und schon in der letzten Sendung haben wir ja diesen schönen Titel souverän
oder souverän verkackt untergebracht.
Und das wird natürlich mit dieser Technologie der künstlichen Intelligenz,
dem Heben von Datenschätzen als Prozess jetzt nicht geschwächt.
Und da sehe ich.
Auf jeden Fall noch die eine oder andere Herausforderung, wenn Menschen,
die diese Technologien bauen, so drauf sind wie Mark Zuckerberg, Peter Thiel,
Elon Musk, da könnte noch eine ganze Menge ethischer Traumvorstellungen, die wir haben,
nochmal auf dem Weg in die goldenen 20er nochmal einer kritischen Prüfung unterzogen werden.
Ich sage da mal nichts zu.
Tja, wir könnten mal über eine, also das sind ja, das sind Gedanken,
die, glaube ich, deren Zeit jetzt in meiner Wahrnehmung dann schon gekommen ist.
Sollte es, also vielleicht werden wir nicht alle arbeitslos.
Oder vielleicht dauert das noch ein bisschen, bis wir alle arbeitslos werden.
Auf jeden Fall, selbst wenn wir nicht alle arbeitslos
werden wird es starke Produktivitätsgewinne geben in den Tätigkeiten mit denen
wir uns heute noch beschäftigen und der Begriff der Automatisierungsdividende
wurde glaube ich auch von Leuten im CCC damals sehr stark schon vor langer Zeit
geprägt dass man sich mal darüber Gedanken macht wie wir,
als Gesellschaften von diesen ganzen Effizienzgewinnen profitieren,
statt dass einzelne Unternehmen, Shareholder oder Einzelfaschisten.
Da jetzt die Machtkonzentration, die Kapitalkonzentration erfahren und nutzen können.
Und vor dem Kontext hin, vor dem Kontext verstehe ich auch, warum die vielleicht
gerade lieber daran arbeiten, dass die Welt sich zersplittert,
und nicht auf, ja, sag ich mal, eine globalisierte Zukunft hinsteuert,
dass du halt Ach, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ach, genug für heute. Das war's.
Kommen wir noch zu einer guten Nachricht. Heute hat es in Berlin nicht mehr
ganz so stark geregnet wie gestern.
Und die Züge fahren wieder.
Das soll eine gute Nachricht sein. Ein bisschen mehr Regen könnte auch helfen.
Ja, genau. Also ihr merkt schon, das war auch so eine ungerichtete Diskussion.
Wir wollten nicht auf irgendwas hinaus.
Es gibt jetzt hier keine Pointe, sondern wir wollten einfach ein bisschen,
wie sagt man so schön, Food for Thought liefern.
Mal auch so ein bisschen selber abwerfen, was eigentlich bei uns so im Kopf
herumkreist und ich denke, ihr werdet da auch noch eine ganze Menge hinzuzufügen haben.
Grundsätzlich möchte ich aber noch anmerken,
Dieser Kulturpessimismus, den wir in Deutschland so gerne pflegen,
der ist meiner Meinung nach jetzt auch nicht so angemessen.
Es ist einfach wieder ein signifikanter Technologieschub, den wir hier erleben.
Es gibt definitiv ein Vor- und ein Nach-AI-Moment in der Geschichte und die
Änderungen werden umwälzend sein. Aber das war halt auch mit den anderen Technologie-Dingen so.
Also was Telefon, Strom, Telefon, Computer an sich, Internet.
Smartphone und jetzt eben auch AI, was das alles für Änderungen bewirkt hat.
Ich werde manchmal irre, wenn ich einfach so ein bisschen älter werde und dann
so dieses, wie war es vor 30 Jahren, wie war es vor 40 Jahren,
wenn man so diese Realität mal daneben hält, womit wir uns heute beschäftigen.
Die Änderungen sind so krass, also würde ich mein Ich von vor 30 Jahren mit
der heutigen Technologieentwicklung und der damit verbundenen gesellschaftlichen
Entwicklung konfrontieren,
dann wäre die Differenz einfach enorm und für mein damaliges Ich kaum zu verstehen.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass man irgendwie nicht
leben könnte oder dass Dinge nicht auch besser geworden sind.
Es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man gerade so eine globale Situation
hat, in der die Dinge sich jetzt auch erstmal wieder so gefühlt verschlechtern.
Mehr Krieg oder der Krieg ist näher, mehr Krieg ist es eigentlich gar nicht,
es ist eigentlich weniger Krieg, aber der Krieg ist uns einfach näher.
Unser politisches System scheint sehr viel mehr in Auflösung und Desorientierung
gefangen zu sein, als es sich vielleicht vor 30 Jahren angefühlt hat.
Trotzdem sind solche Unsicherheiten auch immer wieder da und gehen auch immer wieder weg.
Und es gibt eben verschiedenste Sinuswellen, die nicht alle auf der gleichen
Phase sind von Sachen, die sich verbessern und verschlechtern.
Von daher teile ich einfach diese Weltuntergangsstimmung generell nicht.
Und ich bin auch nicht bereit, sie jetzt an diese Technologie ranzupacken und
zu sagen, ja, wegen AI wird jetzt alles ganz schlimm werden.
Nee, das wird auch ohne AI ganz schlimm werden.
Ja, ich meine, das ist immer die Frage, wie schaut man drauf?
Ja, wir werden alle arbeitslos. Das kann auch einen positiven Aspekt haben.
Wollen wir doch alle ja.
Wenn wir die ganze Zeit arbeiten. Also, ja, am Ende, wir wollen natürlich weiter existieren.
Wir wollen eine Gesellschaft haben, die nicht auseinander trifft.
Ich glaube, das ist das, glaube ich, was wir alle unterschreiben würden.
Das ist das, was ich persönlich am schlimmsten finde.
Alle politischen Bewegungen, egal ob sie jetzt auf technologischer Entwicklung
basieren oder eben aus rein gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen heraus,
aber alles was dazu führt, dass die Unterschiede in der Gesellschaft stärker auseinander driften.
Das halte ich für schlecht. Und alles, was man dazu nutzen kann,
um diese Differenzen wieder zusammenzubringen, das halte ich für gut.
Und das kann man irgendwie mit der einen und mit der anderen Technologie machen
und manchmal geschieht es auch automatisch einfach aus einem Wandel heraus,
der dann eben einfach von,
ja vielleicht auch mal von Langeweile getragen ist, weil Leute dann einfach
gar keinen Bock mehr haben, sich mit Computern und AIs zu unterhalten,
sondern einfach ganz bewusst auf einmal andere Dinge wieder mehr wertschätzen.
Und so gibt es immer wieder so ein Bounceback. Deswegen wird schon nicht alles so schlimm werden.
Ich würde auch wirklich sagen, dass das ja auch wirklich eine ganz,
also eine wirklich faszinierende Technologie ist.
Das dürfen wir bei all dem nicht vergessen.
Als Nerd bin ich begeistert.
Und vielleicht kann ich hier einen kleinen Text zitieren, den ein paar Leute
vor vielen Jahren formuliert haben, als eine neue Technologie drohte,
alle Bereiche des Lebens zu durchdringen.
Der Text wurde irgendwann so im August,
September 1981 in der Tageszeitung Die Taten formuliert und ich werde ihn jetzt
leicht verändert vortragen, Dass die innere Sicherheit erst durch KI-Einsatz möglich wird,
glauben die Mächtigen heute alle.
Dass KI nicht streikt, setzt sich als Erkenntnis langsam auch beim mittleren Unternehmen durch.
Dass durch KI-Einsatz das Telefon noch schöner wird, glaubt die Telekom heute
mit ihrem KI-System in Feldversuchen beweisen zu müssen.
Dass der KI-Assistent nun in Deutschland dem Netflix-gesättigten BMW-Fahrer
angedreht werden soll, wird durch die nun einsetzenden Anzeigenkampagnen klar.
Dass sich mit neuronalen Modellen trotz alledem sinnvolle Sachen machen lassen,
die keine zentralisierten Großorganisationen erfordern, glauben wir.
Damit wir als KI-Freaks nicht länger unkoordiniert vor uns hinwuseln,
tun wir was und treffen uns.
Hervorragend.
Ja, was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Tschüss.
Tschüss sagen wir einfach. Ich glaube auch, Leute.
Das war's. Wir wünschen euch eine entspannte Woche und wir hören uns bald wieder. Bis bald.
Bis bald.